[Musique]
alors je vais essayer de vous récupérer
tout comme il faut les caméras et tout
parce que ça a bougé depuis tout à
l'heure
et donc c'est pour ça que je vais
récupérer ça je vais suivre les joueurs
histoire de pas rater le début du match
et puis toute façon on va être ensemble
pendant plus de mal au cul la cgt l'a
alors à temps car il faut que m la
caméra les autres mon avis vous devez la
caméra c'est le bourba thabeet faire
c'est de le truc pour avoir planté ces
élections oui tu penses que vinci n'ont
pas de caméras ainsi longtemps qu'ils
pas de caméra non je sais pas où est
je t'entends pas du tout je pense que ça
rien de ta connection pas parce que pour
le moment le jeu on voit le flux
correctement ok alors du coup ce que tu
peux porter de faire c'est naples et sur
l'autre au skype je vais tenter sa
neuvième tessa on va s'gêner taux réduit
a tout tenté ça alors ouais ouais ok
mieux non voilà c'est la honte en temps
ok bon bah écoute c'est mieux comme ça
c'est comme ça je suis en train de
récupérer les caméras des joueurs
j'entends récupère très bien bon ok ok
après moi je pensais mieux 104 photos de
moi comme tube avec le singe n'importe
qui sait pas où est cette photo
d'ailleurs je pense en photo sinon
j'aime être en plein écran fait un très
très heureux de me voir ta seconde est
là pour toi mais je sais mais en fait
magnus et higuain 9 joue pour moi en
fait c'est pas faux que le sache c'est
que ils se sont appelés le relief
on a envie de jouer pour qu'avant fait
un dernier arrêt aux floralies bocquet
coiffe un jour d'ailleurs on va voir
retomber ce tournoi-là dhabi stream cup
dont je sais pas quoi d'ailleurs les
candidats ça a été renommé les candy
stream 1 avec crash en fait sont partir
avec bitstream et claudie crash en fait
fantastique faut le savoir je suis fan
cadres et des joueurs la fab
je suis un peu en galère avec ça ok moi
je serai bon je suis sur une chaise
comme j'ai fait following bus carlson ça
devrait commencer la discipline ça
devrait commencer à dissiper a fortiori
tabac d'abord d'une forme ça y est c'est
parti
double 4 et c'était pas du spa du fisher
ce sont des échecs alors attends je veux
qu alger mais la brise la ruse battant
je te laisse commencé à commenter ce cas
moi je suis un peu en difficulté en
temps avec mon cadrage des joueurs bon
leur semble juste
je vous des coûts très classique pour
nous qu'on connaît bien très reese est
ce qu elle qualifie sa faute tout de
suite dès le 4ème vous dommage mais non
du coup on tourne aux noms de la pire
assez calme côté blanc cas et c6 ok donc
5 ou classique on peut se réfugier 4
impressions sur le centre et sur des 5
juste au ramen lecavalier à la maison et
après on va attaquer le centre avec ses
six sous ie6 donc là je sais pas ce que
va jouer 12 une offre s'il veut faire
flouer 3 ou des cinq centrales c'est les
coûts choisi dans l'autre est donc aisé
elle a préparé aux 5 ou après refuge et
4 pour aller chercher qu'à liège 3 faire
pression sur sur des quatre ans soit toi
donc déjà grosse réflexion de design of
à noter qu'arsenal qui sait s'ils
savaient jouer à 6o de la pire de
l'année dernière il avait gagné donc
faudra jouer donc là-bas au km h 05
roger kassé l'autre option le 5 très
bien et l'a donc deux écoles sont
échanges sont tous premiers échanges et
peut-être tranquille ou s'il pousse ça
va ressembler une sorte d' estaing diène
un peu la position 5 en vue qu'elle est
le sept ou bon d'être assuré de
reprendre à québec 8 mai en tout cas
sûrement le plan havrais sera jake f5
donc qu'il est prise et dessus tom c1
sur un possible poursuit rector d1 ou
alors ils échangent les dames et de
faire des échanges massif quoi dans le
truc plus tranquille
le risque de perdre quoi que c'est con
carne scène c'est que ça lui va bien ce
genre de de position et peut manoeuvrer
tranquille donc donc à voir
on ne sait pas donc la joie ignorant je
regarde pas la partie donc là soit une
info la nature les airs et infos pour le
moment je sais pas trop quelle position
symétrique
voilà tout récupérer je suis en train de
banco kefu g4 jouer en f1 ok bon bah les
blancs gloucester pièce rare que les
noirs maintenant on peut faire peut-être
comme à six et huit épreuves sur bessin
et qu'on peut faire flouer fuite aussi
j'imagine pour réactiver ce chou qui
disons-le en g7 ne fait plus grand chose
après une option se faire [ __ ] un f3
suis parquet et des quatre ans celle qui
sait si ce parce qu'on sait que c'est
quelqu'un sait si ce n'est pas idéal
il serait mieux en 17 ans l'adoption ces
6 voilà pour bien contre la casse des 5
ce qu'on voit dans la fille dort donc là
d'ouverture bon voilà plusieurs options
pour les noirs ce que tu voudrais me
dire qu'à chez moi se fout que je
n'oserais voir ouais quelque part que
chez moi tu sais deux fois tout le monde
on adore y en a quatre qui dégage
on ad'ailleurs d'ailleurs n'a plus qu'un
l'ablation d'un fou là attention et il a
suivi par québec alex telle option
alors là c'est qu'il est bien il veut
enlever pour faire nul il faut prendre
des quatre qui est des cinq pour voir
les photos qu'on leur pose à paraître et
ses ex terrain les jeux super chanson
c'est sûrement la meilleure option
je te dire enfin là je vais venir au
soutien là je vais ces cas là tu es
comme dans un bol
là tu étais tout seul à pousser et là
j'arrive c'est le talonneur qui envoie
le ballon
well as régulateur là j'arrive 20 pouces
trop honteux
moi je pense que j'ai tout misé les
caméras des joueurs je les recadrer un
peu de tout à l'heure j'ai ma caméra
j'ai le chronomètre
j'ai léger les parties y aura le score
qui va s'afficher on est royal on est
royal fab bon on est jeune tu as fait ta
petite coiffure tout se mange et la
coiffure
j'ai regardé les regarder un peu de
tennis j'ai tout fait et d'ailleurs
demain je t'annonce la défaite de nadal
contre contreras ch à 9 tours assez joué
par je m'attendais par contre il protège
son fion quel point f3c 6th 5 tu vas
souffrir un peu
on ne peut pas faire tout ce que je
raconte est ce qu'il y ait encore des
trucs croise à tout est bon je vais
laisser sisters et nous empêchent 6 jean
pêche
bon bah c'est bien ça c'est pour perdre
pied bessat qui ne vous embêtez pas est
ce qu est ce que tu as un petit prono la
d'avant match tu penses provient plus
douce plus 13 g pas massacre je sais pas
quel point carlos à notre enragé quoi
bon score bonne bonne avance
j'ai un peu récupéré c'est ce que disent
ce que disait ce qu'est ce que dit un
peu le chat on est combien je sais pas
combien on est je sais même pas combien
tu as là on était sur youtube ya
personne qui me répond pas personne ne
me parle en fait personne ne me parle
les gens l'ignorent non mais je leur ai
dit que c'est à leur bas on en parlera
après mais vite vite fait je leur
expliquais que je voulais stream un peu
autre chose que les échecs
j'ai demandé des conseils mais les mecs
étaient pas très coopératif si bon il ya
toujours tu allais franck les machins
fois qu'ils sont toujours là présent à
donner des bons conseils à tuer les
historiques j'irai mais ils sont pas
faciles mais nouveau dans le cul par des
chocs et c'est tout non mais qui trop
les sdf du billboard très intéressant
2020 mais bon ça c'est une idée ça non
mais tu vois je voulais faire un fait
mais je sais pas si tu es chaud mais
j'ai rien qu'on fasse un civilisation 6
mais tu vas civilisation 6 dans l'esprit
autour des grog civilisation grob quoi
bas une civilisation géré les mecs te
demandent enfin une utilisation très
belliqueuse quoi je dois croire en la
dignité grog sinon région tu dégages les
pignons je te fais des traités de paix
mais la paix c'est un morceau de pain
que je t'envoie pour te défoncer plus
tard c'est une situation très hostile en
fait c'est aussi l'été maximum mais qui
est capable de faire un truc
complètement con à certains moments ça
regarde mais qui attaque une ville je
décide de ne pas la défendre prend là ça
ne m'intéresse pas tu dégages mémé
habitants ne m'intéresse plus tu vois un
truc vraiment dans l'esprit à fond mais
bon j'ai pas ce sont 7 à peine rentable
pas donc le bon là c'est complètement
égal l'aigoual s'ils allaient changer
tout ça à la 7e place
c'est à dire sithanen alors est ce qu
est ce que la stratégie de boucé enough
ce serait pas de venir jouer le plus
longtemps possible cette position pour
essayer de faire le moins de partir de
la maison jour il peut la perdre ou pas
qui verrait 9
ouais ouais pas toutes les deux choix
possibles avancées pour contraindre à la
pendule à six constats jouer sur trois
secondes tout ça mais bon sang quelle
page charles opposé d'un flambeau en
cette fin il ya une énorme différence
par rapport à cape town mais j'ai déjà
croisé plusieurs tournois le mec est bon
et en blitz il est bon aussi que
normalement il n'ya pas de chance il
tombe sur un apparemment assez dur quoi
malgré cela on a pareillement plus
facile en fait c'est un peu la question
qu'on se pose en fait non mais bon
jusqu'à 7 c'est le pire après moubarak
ali serait
et mal aussi mais c'est déjà un peu
moins dur et que c'était un expert 4/4
ya kim peut-être pas des chances c'est
par un tête à queue 20% mais c'est déjà
quelque chose là bas on lui donne zéro
c'est pas trop mais en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que tu te rappelles on avait
dit avant le match meilleur car yakine
que meyer avait peut-être un peu de
chance ou quoi il s'était fait démolir
en fait ouais pour le second mais je
pense en fait que ce format là ça
favorise vraiment le joueur qui est plus
fort en fait parce que tu joues trop de
partis sur un match je vais 25 parties
et c'est quelque part c'est plus des
vrais échecs que les partis classiques
où il peut y avoir des surprises est
plus du tout partie
we had sur place oui les gens c'est plus
des vrais échecs ça en fait il ya moins
de surprise c'est ça représente plus la
force du joueur les librairies
classiques - tu vois c'est à lire quand
même ce facteur chance qui est un peu
dérangeant que t'as pas dans le dans le
formamide s'en fait qu'ils enlèvent
vraiment la chance ça c'est intéressant
c'est plus intéressant est complètement
déments démonstration par l'absurde en
fait est en fait en plus c'est
complètement vrai ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est ça le plus drôle
donc la fab on sent quand même
gousseïnov qui va la merde bas il fait
tout pour quoi ils essayent quoi qu'il
en soit il y avait un truc tout
symétrique il me restera toujours pas
s'il sera une peau de banane un moment
c'est possible
il veut y annoncer avoir du tout raciste
tour des six avec beckham qui arrive
enfin le thème quand on verra trois ou
six mois six toiles à tomber si c'est
juste trop bien peut être
il faut deux mains sur france 4
après pas un truc magnus je sais pas ou
pas sur un peu en pls calme à la place
de ces neuf je parraine us il fait peur
d'abord c'est cet endroit protégé il va
ramener son rang ces cinq jours arrive à
ramener le roi que je sais c'est trop
c'est ça qu'on va ranger le fou ils
veulent planter son fou pour ce qu' il
va peut-être se sauver tu trouves pas
que c'est un peu du masochisme ce qu'on
est en train du sadisme ce qu'on est en
train de faire new way
non nous ne fait rien on commence avec
quelques mois enfin enfin afin de
commenter une mise à mort c'est là c'est
la corrida gousseïnov tu sais pas s'il
va pas se prendre ceci donne genre tout
reprend des six fou prend ses 4 et tour
des huit comme ça je veux rentrer en d2
sur échec et il doit y avoir du roi b3
la fin est bon maintenant mais ils
jouent un très grand jeu hier soir les
bleus à tenir
il fallait tenir tranquille a pas passé
par là mais dans une position maintenue
ce qui laisse v5 pour marquer au fer
phosphate en v3 j'entends une vie cela
qui vient d'arriver à 8
miaou miaou qaïda mais je souhaite que
les deux cantons - l'as bompas je suis
restée brièvement le truc c'est que
femme je pense juste qu'il n'a aucun
respect en fait bah si mais pas trop
mais un peu quand même
on va vite c'est quand même grâce matin
je le respecte et vous c'est d'informer
le vent je me suis dit je respecte
beaucoup mais en fait non non mais là ok
il peut pas perdre devant nous et en
plus c'est lui qui a des chances regard
finalement excaf et magnus je sais pas
pourquoi il a fait ça
les sites mais ok mais imagine le truc
c'est pas assez nadal contre le 250e
mondial c'est en cinq sets gagnants
cousineau
enfin nul et c'est normal
les pions c'est de la merde j'ai vu le
il a vu le prix string bitstream en fait
débat je m'en fous quand je le match
tombait elle a raison c'est 80 aura deux
arrivent à wade c'est fini c'est fini tu
dégages
or met au rap et 3 bien mais bon trajet
de l'acte iii n'en ratent entoure c'est
un tour c'est un plus non mais attends
il peut peut-être la tenir à tour doublé
33e potable ouais mais roi perdue frappé
de turf est un échec
les gens à utiliser du temps qu'on fasse
très attention bien sûr ça va être
fantastique ce match on va pas eu grand
condé pour qu'il finisse fanni en fait
c'est horrible les journées marre d'être
du côté des perdantes et d'être du côté
du poulidor non je suis pas pour polydor
eddy merckx hashtag l'intérim eddy
merckx le cannibale batou recettes et
puis maintenant je te pousse les pions à
temps est ce que c'est si facile que ça
m6 tous rêvent sa gestion a tancé même
intéressant fait de regarder ça comment
magnus gagne ça c'est très instructif
je n'en attends là c'est trop
pédagogique là ce qui est en train se
passe à québec la plongée de et on va
traiter ans est donc c'est la menace
donc du coup il veut jouer un livret jeu
truqué que leur couper sinon et
française prince et s'attèlera et couper
ses gagnants je pense si nietzsche de
retour allez y à deux tours c'est
bizarre d'autre part on connaît ses
positions avec une tour le tour ne
connaît pas non mais ok mais je vois mal
gousseïnov tenir 50 magnus mais on va
voir dans la nuit ça va faire purger 5 à
5,3 et ici ça tient une proposition je
détour leçon aux médailles et ceux des
coups mais non mais c'est logique de
faire ça
la farouche huit mois la partie civile
peut durer si son couple de n'est pas
pour ces cinq retours à toi de cash
devrait tomber 5 et chaque recteur
ouais mais bon autant quand même plus
qu'avant bref il va y avoir des menaces
de maths un petit à petit ça c'est
génial mais il résiste bien en poche un
sens rare sans rigoler comme le taureau
il donne de quoi coup de corne quoi
attention bel effort qu'on en fait pas
trop peur pour le torero ce soir
derrière le torero mais il m'a menacé
matt de l'escalier du coup on est obligé
de courir avec une tour convoité par et
échanger une tour c'est génial ça
t'oblige à l'euro à couper à les mecs et
dans le chat de check point comme ils
écrivent lol ben gousseïnov fils enlevé
la caméra ça et là il a déconné que la
caméra permet là je ne veux pas faire de
plus c'est fantastique surtout que je ce
match à la caméra le mieux en flou elle
est là caméra et coucou la caméra je
suis là ça m a remis
ouais magnus en train de parler à
quelqu'un oui mais l essor bon bah allez
le fanny quoi ces partis quoi vous êtes
ses cinquièmes 3g 6 à 3 tiens je suis je
te fais b4y a redonné trois lycées pas
étrange le casse
est ce que la question voire envie de se
poser est ce que magnus trichant
évidemment très étrangère on se dit
tiens speech est championne disais je
suis champion du monde et si je te bats
carrière en mer ouais pour un match que
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à gagner sinon
glisser notre beaucoup trop fort pour
moi même en train de manger d'ailleurs
magnus tranquille les yeux je n'ai pas
fini de qualité tout au bout ouais j'y
fais nous plaisir
je faire en fait je pense que la caméra
s'est dit c'est interdit aux moins de
dix-huit j'enlève la caméra de ghadir je
pense à ce point comme ils sont dits las
twitch ils vont nous virer on peut pas
se permettre à des enfants qui regardent
il a remis la caméra il a l'air en pls
total on est méchant mais malgré cet
article 3 les op online tout est flou
savez quoi ni fort qu'il a commencé à le
troll et puisqu'il ya pas le flag robe
il ne faut pas les meilleurs d'ouverture
bayrou s'est d'ores et déjà c'est un
train en train de le csu et les yeux
quoi tient lieu de quoi beaucoup trop
compliquée j'en peux plus mais c'est
horrible on rigole mais séverine pas
assez c'est dur ce qu'il est vraiment
fort en fait sans rire contre quelqu'un
là iront à l'examen des eaux mais bon
avec un sun c'est vraiment pas le bon
joueur pour lui en plus c'est en fait
découvert une position technique qui va
le dans la partie d'avant incroyable qui
s'est passé tellement nul voilà position
foot que leur opposer machin ya plus
rien ce coup symétrique et puis donc
mais on vous écrit même son éclairage et
dépressif
non mais c'est l'éclat d'un coup ça
c'est fantastique quand tu as les deux
sur la camarade magusi les parties s'est
levé by cc pas levé s'est décalé il se
barre en fait
shana 30 du fait des trucs en fait ça et
c'est fantastique quand tu as les deux
sur la carte sur un manuscrit père
tranquille avec ses petites lunettes
tranquille ou bien éclairé et tu vois la
rockhal et agustin 9 mai mais en pls de
niveau 5 100 tu vois à ces gestes est
toujours le faire défoncer
non mais c'est chiant même pour lui en
pâtissait cas peut-être demir c'est sûr
il ya des milliers personnes qui
regardent disait le taureau quoi il
s'est mis la main à la main lara sur le
front heureusement il ya pas blake qui
commente
il a beaucoup de chance gousseïnov vient
de perdre une oreille là le taureau
bannissez regarde la position de l'or
mais c'est qui lui au fait je pense va
faire f4 f5 sur plein de trucs tu es
tellement bien positionnement des
meilleures structures tout est bien le
fou dessin qui rayonne la structure
leroy faible en face vient de partout
fausses histoires quand bessette
comptoir des peintures r ça tombe bien
ce bientôt déjà là pendant les jours les
gens sont méchants disney jamais vu
kevin aussi moqueur nom soit faut
arrêter je me demande très souvent des
adversaires et moi même d'ailleurs je
suis le premier à dire que je suis un
idiot fini ce qui est tout à fait vrai
dire
fabien tu me connais bien tu sais que au
niveau débilité je suis ceinture noire
voilà des x men tu me dis je vais enfin
on discute en off
tu me disais je me trouvais débile mais
maintenant que je t'ai rencontré tutu
voilà nos chocolats je sens que j'ai de
la marche ouais c'est ça c'est mais
c'est clair je le dis souvent aux gens
parlent encore avec ma tête ma femme
hier soir je suis et fabien ils
pensaient qu'ils étaient débiles avant
j'ai une idée il a compris que c'est un
amateur je fais une échappée à cela
non mais à me disais était complètement
d'accord mais elle me connaît encore
mieux que toi donc amené encore il dit
qu'à y connaît pas encore l'ampleur du
truc quoi mais la science eu recours
efficaces au monde fou aux 7
il faut qu'on dise les soupes rendez
saha à elle est tombée en premier tombée
en premier puis ça revient au même
vous tournez ça être un tout en fait
damak attribués
gigote fait peut-être faire tourner bien
des têtes maximum à maxima magnus c'est
un peu un peu facile mais bon après tout
dire fou prend la fuite d'un prendre ça
très proche de sa 3e set d'america trop
plein gré mais c'est moi je pense tour
bien été plus fort bond chevaleresque
ben sinon même tour c'est ça tu
t'attendais micky qui veut que tu qu
utilise juste que tu commentes un peu
plus la partie fabien il ment il écrit
pas pour toi mais il sent que tu
commandes pas assez non banon mais sa
cave bon voilà alors qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire la tour 17 et attaquer il faut
trouver de solution n'a trouvé ni maman
j'ai un pion très bien du coup on a une
aronde voir enlever la tour et fuite
alors où ça va selon lui de france et
vivrait en lice fo f6 pépère propose
échange des fous à la fin qui s'avère
bien plus avec les blancs on est
invaincu en bon bah c'est pas mal bon
avion c'est déjà ça talent pur des 5
passes et le roi noir est faible et bon
hockey et à des quatre qui peut sauter
peut-être aussi donc ça fait beaucoup de
choses je pense que
parce que peut-être tour c'est ici sur
ces quatre epr au nom des quatres un
petit à petit combat cessa pour ces
systèmes puissent aller bien intouchable
tu peux la prendre et ça nous recrutions
même même temps que je passe y ont fait
tomber 1 mais peut-être jonathan poèmes
et pourrait faire tomber jette mais
ouais tu sc2 de tomber sa de moquer ça
devrait bon je trouvais qu un peu la vie
peut-être un peu peut-être la difficulté
c'est là je pense que magnus un moment
donné elle était un peu trop facile il
avait une position plus simple mais bon
le seul truc qui peut arriver à ma guise
entre guillemets c'est un peu de sortir
de son match
éventuellement d'y retourner à touristes
raspaillou non seulement il est en train
de calculer je pense c'est compliqué
pour nous mais pas pour lui
j'ai trois pas mal aussi comme ça il
pourra sur un échec sur la première il
pourra mettre le ranger de direct qui
protège le pion à f2 ouais plus quand
même deux rois de mach 1 h mans s'est
offert tout reprend un système français
2 quand même ce que tu fais pas
maintenant tu fais quoi
durant ces 2 et puis tu te bats quoi il
allait la voir son tir bas serait donc
c4 et c4 plus d'avant au jet d'une
petite subtilité barrette humains
souffrent des quatre haies dames f6
présent parce logique mais de quoi
prendre du fou et on projette à 9,6 le
verre utilisé avec le coup j'ai trois
chez pas abattu tu défends h4 en fait
peut-être oui parce que sinon je vais
montrer si on avait fait ces quatre
avant il y aurait eu plus on prend vous
pouvez mettre le pied en c3 sachant la
foux prend et d'un prend h4 et ça va
contrôler la case f6 antec g3 négatif on
va te faire la batterie blonde et à
l'envié de la voile est matière à schwyz
beaucoup torse les 6-17 ou raciste
ok mais en plus sur ce projet cette
épreuve sert non non il veut faire
tourner 8 après force est ce une vraie
fuite mais peut-être qu'il joue pas mal
là ghoussein a faim on rigolait vous
rigolez mais non mais il s'accroche
évidemment en fin de vie et lui de 1650
mais bon elle sait qu'il ya une défense
au niveau encore en train très fort
grands maîtres à 2650 l'élite mondiale
très fort très fort grand maître est
très fort 8 ça rend plus ce que c'était
en réalité le bit baisse pour les séries
en fait ils se retrouvent entre eux et
ils passent leurs jeunes habitent avec
mamediarov avec booth et à miami
ouais radjabov toute cette bande voyage
se passe car jackée avec toi peut-être
mais je sens plus les autres faire les
400 coups ensemble quoi là la bande sa
ferrari avait tort que ces enough et
mêmes m'hamed chez va peut-être faire
tourner ses quatre tours des 4 et 7 mais
bon ils sont et c'est tous des bons
beats armées azéries belle mais ça il
passera après la personne ça joue sajou
ou sajoo en qui ils ont une bonne main
ils ont les points réflexes et d'anne
decis j'ai vu bouzinac la peur de jouer
le tournoi par teachers en corse et dans
les parties lentes en fait au kef à
nantes et leurs trente à trente secondes
quand c'était les ait note à la fin à
chaque fois il a oublié à quoi est il
fallait compte d'alimenter il est arrivé
retourne à un truc incroyable
les battues jean-pierre c'est un truc
qui devait pas gagner
ok ça lui fait pas peur je manque de
temps quand tu vois qu'il est bon et
juste à l'essai de la gagne à 5h sant ou
tour where to race est non peut-être
mais je pense que avec un jeu parfait
c'est peut-être sauvable ça pour les
noirs
mais bon c'est ça à ses joueurs de
position parfaite il possible non mais
là ça va faire un quatre contre trois
qui doit être mieux quand même même été
encore des courses est quand j'essaie
tout qua non ouais mais tu peux
peut-être mètres la tour un f6 effet le
f4 leroy monte je sais pas je tenterai
ça réclame 1,5 sur une bouée 3g / f4 tu
fais 5 mai as tu veux cinq quand même je
pense mais f3 ou kg 3g 4g bien le mal
mais c'est pas mal ça n 3 et 4
mais quand même me caméra me de mal
pas cher on a un azéri dans le chat qui
écrivent centre de ce qu en azéri mais
je ne peux pas comprendre
freak n'chic kasparov et azéri aussi
sport n'a été gagné à baby jane à bas
coûts le tigre de l'ogre de boeuf ou
l'ogre bon ben j'ai quatre années plus
tôt au goût plutôt tigre claude le tigre
c'est l'amanda tarn le tigre celtique de
madras à nantes nice qui vient de madras
logique mais auquel madras dire qui
était retombé chennai manager n'est pas
près de changer les menus mais voilà tu
pourras toujours way cents soit un peu
moins bien avant non j'ai une mini des
connexions là ça va ou alors cette
finale mais ce doit être nul ça non bon
sang mais en fait ok je comprends pas
qu'il veut faire court il veut faire
soit tour j'ai ici sous veut peut-être
faire aussi touché 5 et te mettre en
joue donc en fait
et l'écart des taux à six mois du tour
j'ai cinq mois mais tourache 8 oued
examen des quatre mais prennent surtout
la richesse des quatre il y avait 3 3 je
vais maintenant me rajeunit arrivé à
tours derrière roy houleux mais le roi
des soirées ont le droit chemin
maintenant et maintenant peut-être coup
d'attendre un coup d' atroce quelque
chose pour les fils forcer beaucoup
d'attentes
là je sais pas sa personne
car ce qui s'est passé nous si je sais
pourquoi on redescend en effet retour
effet en dessous mais je suis dit que
les fluctuations tout à fait apte il
veut faire sur oise et 5e l'effet retour
et fait roi reprend 2,5 et tuez pas
reprendre de faire trop d 4 je pense
frais mais le truc c'est qu'il n'arrive
pas à faire voyager 7,3 g 8 se ride pour
lui c'est horrible et h 8
fini le fardeau si incroyable technique
je vais tout petit tour au propre
monstre qu'est ce qui se passe de god
hand on lâche non je veux dire dans ton
avec son internet cela se sent en
difficulté tout d'un coup bien ma vie
j'ai refait le cas ici six vaches
sentant plus du tout j'étais perdu perdu
fabien pour le moment donc ça va nous ça
nous transposer dans un genre de 20
joueurs de pire que tout ça comme si
c'est le 4-5-1 relief 3d 6,30 avec
fougue et 3 je n'ai pas forcément les
finesses de tout ça mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on a perdu femme et qu'on va le
retrouver où je connais pas les fesses
tout ça alors il enlevait ou et sa tête
un peu ressembler où je tape les flammes
alors tu vas tu m'entends ouais je
t'entends
vous aimez les gars venu guitare âge à
tout le monde il a donc fait la grande
au stage ah ah ah ah ah ah oui c'est
mieux là la banque est en silicone et là
c'est bon passé c'est déjà mieux du coup
on va juste me reconnecter et c'est ce
que me poursuivre les parties à noter un
pour le score du match j'avais tout
simplement à côté du nom des jouets à
serres classées 2 0 juste pour les gens
qui veulent le score il est écrit à
gauche des joueurs j'ai pas les mêmes
avaient fait que les gens entendent bien
parce que moi j'ai un petit un petit
espèces depuis que j'entends en font
quand même mais c'est que c'est plus mon
nico mais parfois y'a que moi qu'il
entend tout ce que vous avez vérifié
donc c'est une ouverture un peu bizarre
un fab voilà donc en train de tomber
dessus la caisse et que ça je veux
regarder qu'un seul donc au pied ok ok
je vois voyage ici dessus j'ai juste vu
personne n'a envie qu'on entend ni tête
c'est moi en fait c'est ça arrive en
fait j'ai déjà remarqué en replay que
j'entendais plus de sons parasites que
les gens voient dans le jeu reprend
jusqu'à l'ouverture du fou des proches
bleus et de ses 32 pire vieille indienne
ouais c'est un mélange d'un peu tout
c'est une position très ferme et est en
fait ce qui est un peu marrant c'est que
magnus il a réussi à fermer la lhdaa
mais il va envoyer ses pions à l'est le
roi tu arrives à faire du cavalier h5 a
valu à cadouin ce qui est en train
d'arriver et envoyé f5 et tout est en
fait ils s'en fichent france de prendre
de perdre le pion bekaert ce que faisait
3 reprend mais qu'a t'il pas seulement
le fou en v6 passé ça c'est
tons chauds de cases noires commence à
être très bon corps quatre candidats
plus d'opposants mais ça que vous avez
nord c'est le genre de truc qui comprend
très bien puisque c'est lui est un bon
joueur d'instinct diène et donc leur
besoin qu'elle est à l'aise côté noir
mais parfois c'est pas forcément ce que
c'est parce que t'es allé ce côté noir
que tu es allé ce côté blanc à
l'évolution tu que tu joues bien avec
une couleur spécifiquement en fait alors
est ce qu'on peut faire tout reprend 1,3
et cavaliers ces deux ici côté magnus va
bien tu peux
voilà fait qualifié de directe dans le
même esprit encore mieux puisque tu
auras la tour qui leur arrive en a3 ça
je pense qu'il n'avait pas vu boussaïna
fin non il remue la tête encore non les
maires de cette faire une recette fait
une raison la dérogation en fait peut
juger des finales les 2 partout où un
parti du match ça donne un récital
non mais je pense que ma nuit ici là
pour s'amuser la pince et je suis même
pas sûr qu'ils fassent un score tu vois
là + 20 ou un truc comme ça ça se peut
qu'ils lâchent un peu à un moment donné
je pense que tu vois il est enfin il
n'est pas du tout sous tension non il ya
une trop grosse et un trop gros écart
puis surtout qu'il n'a pas eu le temps
de douter en fait il met directement 2 0
alors le 4k celles ci sont normales et
qui s'appelle milovic ouais je crois que
ça peut être ça le truc c'était
énormément de transposition oui je sûr
que les trois très souvent alors je veux
juste eu 5 et chansons avec 4,5 peut
aussi jouer truc avec des cinq est
transposée dans un commentaire dans une
sordide a donc là et les noirs ils
attaquent à fond allèles dame ils ont
poussé les pions un peu vraiment comme
dans une est indienne tu pousses le jeu
est fermé sur au centre donc on pousse
sur les ailes et les blancs normalement
sans séjour à l'ale dame mais bon on
voit ta tour pour arrivant à 7 mais elle
ferait pas énormément non plus quoi sur
internet a créé 17 noms pourraient
défendre d'une manière x ou y
déjà si nous apportons la confortable
aux et noir non
parce que l'internet coup pour coup à sa
base s'était pas faite aux peines et
complète sur la connexion téléphonique
2010 et a fait monter les gens
l'appellent samassa me couche je le
reconnais qu'avec vous l'appelez je vais
accoucher de voir leur accroche
mais j'aime bien j'aime bien sûr de
magnus dahl et blanc faudrait qu'ils
puissent être inquiets revenir au 4 mai
ils sont et du bal par du coup je me
fous g5 j'aime bien voilà j'ai 5 et 3
puis de tourgéville où toi si tu
rajoutes est d'ailleurs un pur pour un
peu protégé les cases sur la troisième
patrick matile en pole et d'art g6 avec
la dame ouvert h6 peut-être ça le
problème alors mesdames g6 gilbert
ensuite à venir tu as toutes les pièces
qui permet le hyper bien placé avec les
noirs
jean roch et les lieux on sait pas ce
qu'il va devenir oui madame se ranger
ici t'as pas tant de faire qualité 3
puisque sur calais détroit tu te fais
tout échange en d3 et tu perds est
d'enfin de variantes et h3 logique et la
paire de phu binh on voir comment vont
les cases blanches autour du roi
c'était dingue ou comme fou ces deux qui
permet au prochain et peut-être un
portable de file des formes et des
genres découverte qu'un notebook ou
rouge et 4 je peux pas aller sur cavani
apprend à faire bouger 4 donc hyper dur
à jouer pour les vocations
[Musique]
les perdants faut peut-être joué tour f3
pour essayer de faire diversion on était
dans le cadre maintenant le cadet qu'ils
font quatre ce qu'adam etg part de fuji
4 en fait
donc est-ce qu'on peut jouer quatre ans
philippe sion fils un pion pour t'ouvrir
en plus je suis même pas sûr l2 et puis
sinon même si jamais ce qu'ils ont
dispersé ce matin très grave parce que
tu as dame qui vient vers des cas tels
shopping.com appareils 6 des quatre
aussi ça les dames bello qui était
possible fin ça m'intrigue côté dames
tour 8 la même pas le nom de suite à
l'annoncé d'un décès de mme j 6 us epa
au couple que le scrutin ne peut pas
faire fouiller 4 avec l'idée sur dame
pranger quatre dames point f de roanne
damev en échec à ypres en f1 et tours
troyes et formate si c'était possible ça
marche et ça a l'air fort f1 et
maintenant c'est sous les 4 ça marchait
maintenant que tu veux juste ce rapport
cette petite il n'y a pas de bruit média
n'y a pas de coup de bambou immédiat
messi fait cavalier de 3 après est ce
qui va pas réussir finalement apte
empêcher de s'approcher des cases
blanches un peu mais bon après ça c'est
tragique mais oui bien sûr il n'y a pas
de vent pas de bien évidemment je dois
dire si jamais vous vers des quatre
peut-être ou montagne 30 $ prendre du
plomb en image in situ comme d'habitude
fait manger c4 il n'y a pas du tout de
perpétuels et si tu prend du plomb c'est
quoi son idée juste lc3 n'attendiez pas
eu de consignes d'alger simple gratuite
et peut-être dameuse à davos est de
faire ça ok et encore une finale
alors attention la tension autour
surface blanche pour qu'anvers tours l2
mais voyez toujours évident
oui c'est important ça surtout rade toi
même et tu auras de travail tous rêvent
de tours à huit et surtout réussi ce
tour à tour être cadre que tu es juste
acheter
willy dot échec échec peut être pas et
chaque deux tours en europe de l'échec
l'une d'eux il va devoir revenir en juin
avec le roi tournebu guessous barton
j'ai deux lectures bouchage 2 tu vas
faire don des dieux
alors je vais montrer un croisé deux
tours 2 pour attaquer le cavalier le roi
le cavalier bouge la tournée en g2
suroît charles a ramené le foin f3 avec
des douleurs chatel et sur vos iphone tu
prends mon plat tour de juin c'est ce
que l'on sait si bien en train de ce qui
est en train de se passer sur le roi
vent f1 de façon la foudre ne cherchons
plus comment un chien forcé et fouet f3
et on va menacer maths et en peut-être
encore ah oui mais avec tech tour d2 sur
watch en fait encore plus un prochain
tour des de menaces tandis qu'à l'est
les cavaliers le 1.30 se faire lourdes
vous avez dit sa cravate suspense
normalement 3g 6 à la 3 0 direct je dis
rien alors petit petit système de
l'ombre à venir peut-être ou peut-être
h41 rapide
c'est le truc de renom comme maxime ça
un bug a très très bien
il a lui expliqué que les deux couleurs
je me suis fait peur j'ai peur pour eux
j'ai peur pour ghadir vous vouliez dire
à jouer fuji 4e des essais 6 mais voilà
il ya tombe d'un truc connu et plein de
boue les pieds de iasi 3g d'amenée d'eau
mais il ya des femmes est ce que tu
penses que c'est pénible à jouer ce
genre de matches pour pour gagner est ce
que tu penses qui prend du plaisir où tu
penses que comme ça dure trois heures et
demie cccc juste dans ce 3e ben pas moi
ça me ferait très plaisir vu qu'un
simple tu as un mensonge ou 5,6 je perd
5,6 bon ben ok va on sait que tu es plus
fort et bon
voilà c'est pas besoin de faire trois
heures tous les renvois pour toi aussi
parce que moi en fait je me dis que dans
ces matches là faudrait presque au
premier tour avoir quelque chose de plus
court parce que quand ils détalent
différence de niveau fin ça fait
vraiment tout match montre la vidéo
c'est une exécution quand tu as
peut-être du fou g5 qui peut arriver
qu'il y des cinq est ce que ces joutes
[Musique]
tous les cinq sont payantes française et
les positions qui arrive assez souvent
dans les pires cas dans les cinq
donc là l'idée fabien ce serait quoi
pour les blancs bas et si derrière après
un bond qui est des cinq mois les bonnes
conditions où occupé la colonne des mais
en fait c'est pas le genre variante pro
problématique près normalement pour ça
que sur les pierres thé blanc joue
l'attaqué autrichienne f4 ou l'article
ou 3 3 ou comme ça que j'ai cinq ans
elle veut faire payer dès 5 heures que
je pensais de recrutement trois demandes
tu te poser la question ce jour rien
fait pour être accueilli des cas
possibles
d'ailleurs quand même jour que les
ventes est quelque part bon après faut
pas 3 du parc et des cinq intermédiaire
mais bon tu froid 2 coiffe un budget de
3,4 et dames une paire 6 même et [ __ ]
of war 3 qui est des quatre mêmes
sorties et des cinq au virage j'ai
montré la variante avec les fera pièce
pour la lame ou qualité 5 intermédiaire
mais tu proposes vous prend à eux deux
qui apprend le 7 kg 3e set c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas mal de matériel trois
pièces mineurs pour la dame non ça joue
pas clair dans un autre sens qui l'a pas
fait mais ouais vous prenne froid il ya
peut-être juste vous prend aussi tu
gardes la menace et je voulais essayer
des quatre à ce moment là ça donne des
idées simples peut-être super g dames
des six ne sais pas où va t on
on est passé on est patient qui prend
prend qu'à et des sacs et dont on parle
et j'imagine fou g7 un fab la hausse des
coûts de cet essai c'est ce que musique
c'était l'idée de base mais c'est pas
mal ce qu'il fait line il joue
l'activité cette fois ça va siffler
alors c 391 me fais c'est croire cela
permet de couper les oreilles du careï
sa coupe et c'est ce que tu veux en face
book et c3 qui est pas déplacés enfin
seniors d1 qu'il est bien mais on sait 3
est pas terrible mais le fait de mettre
le pion là c'est déjà un petit quelque
chose là ils dominent de kaïs et six en
fait si on compare les pièces y en a un
qui est venu en des simples qui ai pas
vus et ce cavalier on peut pas réussir à
s'en débarrasser genre faire un truc
comme genre cavaliers ses huit cavaliers
ou six mais j'imagine sûr qu'elle avait
des mythes il veut faire b4 et la dame
peut se retrouver sans casque si elle va
verser 6 sur les cavaliers cet échec
donc il pourrait se retrouver sur des
mauvaises casse donc pas facile et si
fait cavalier e set j'imagine qu'il veut
faire b4 quand même ouais monde un des
six pilotes mais mais qu'avait lieu 3
après deux ou trois ans au 6ème et 5ème
but power s'est lui attaqué de partout
où sa femme dont il a pris le 3e rang et
est maintenant donc sur b4 d'anne decis
forcé mais y aurait pas de bonnes
découvertes
d'accord mais ok je peux dire des cas
d'anne decis des interviews trois mètres
au fond j'étais assis peut justement
régime sinon il ya même un qui dit en
espérant qu'ils ne s'invente pas avant
la fin des trois heures trop fameux 3
aussi qu'il faut toujours garder des
ventes adam des six semaines c'est ce
qu'ils jouent des airs
oui parce que si tu fais dame prend 1,3
et terry prendre cette échelle
intermédiaires se veut être le genre
truc fatale sur faire gaffe et du coup
tu te rossi lui un peu d'avancé ne
faisait rien à des poids lourds était
toujours là tu regardes à sept québécois
il est plus ou moins
j'ai d'aller en russie cet
investissement et qu'est-ce que je pense
que les tours où on va revendre les
télés d'erreur des trois dames en fait
je n'aurais souriez pas juste faire dame
ces cinq peut-être possible c'est
marrant mais ça c'est le truc il car
c'est ni salaire égal mais il ya
toujours un petit plus dans la position
qui y tourne pour lui un peu pénible
parce que là franchement c'est pas loin
de vraiment égal mais j'étais chez en
vain des tarifs jamais complètement il
est natif j'espère tours fc 8 je pense
pas il veut revenir en trois pour
peut-être fait refuge et quatre femmes a
super bien joué c'est super bien joué
qu'à ces deux événements ou pas floués
ont versé 4 c'est un festival
non c'est génial c'est que dans plus de
tournées soit après que c'est le
festival du placement de pièces organisé
par magnus carlsen cette dame c'est 4 6
1 à calculer mais vrai peut-être d'un
programme prend et tour des 8 en rythme
mais bon ya passé dans la zone d'un
dessin du ballon à trois aussi proches
que ce qu'on fait trop même et tu garde
un oeil sur le cavalier pense que ce
soit des cinq races ou sekkat
éventuellement le belge a toujours il
entré en 2e et cavaliers 3 aussi pour
tout chapeauté la pauvre mari chuck &
chabot a les chocottes publiquement
là bas c'est horrible j'espère que vous
sénat ce soir fouga magister en plus
dans la structure d'un autre truc sympa
qu'une ans comptera quatre manches
passées nos échanges détour quoi bon
jour avec les marques changer la carte
b4 tu force a b c d et avions acquis qui
font ces paquets plus chiant combien pas
cette culture c'est cette femme est ce
que tu sens le 4 0
mais la magnus il pourrait chanter et un
et deux et trois zéro là
est à noter à noter aussi que peut pas
jouer tour d un border d'un 3 2 c'est
excitant faire madame monde en corse et
6 pour lutter les monstres on décide
tout le contour d'un thème ça peut
m'intéresser mais là car le stand by les
labels one of man et là c'est le grand
karl scène par l aise en finale les
petits avantages machin g5y empêche
rouge et 4h un qui empêche ces quatre là
est ce que tu es ce qu'on pourrait jouer
g4 la femme dans l'esprit à fond je
jouerai pas mais non moi je le sais car
c'est ça tout ça vous ou je te conseille
à 4 c'est bon là quatre décades de
conserver un montant égal hors contrats
g3 il veut faire quoi il va faire h à 3
h deux fois f1 flash sera je pense pas
je sais pas du tout pensé un plan qui
existent mais ça me paraît du selon bah
ouais ouais mais bon là qu'elle s'écarte
pas mal il attaque le pion mais vous
proposer cette maquette des masses qui
vient de faire c'est ce qu'il vient de
faire
ça va être ça va être très long et très
penny pour gousseïnov mais c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment amusant sur
les caméras et a même pas besoin de de
savoir qui est champion du monde ou quoi
je prends juste souvient sur le stream
et que tu vois les deux caméras dans la
magnus épais plus en phase calme mais si
tu as les deux en face car tu comprends
qu'il est favori du match mais vraiment
direct bloqué depuis tient selon ses
clients il peut pas venir c'est parce
qu'il fait froid il coule troubles à la
rampe et ça non mais cette vision
science mais pas de laisser tomber les
défections non non et connecté il a dans
ce cadre il est devant sa clinique
l'hymne des yeux là il se gratte la tête
je crois qu'il sait parce qu'ici il est
connecté
non mais il est presque ce faire tu as
il es tu vois il est il est là c'est
chez pathé mené 5 0
tu mets un cesse les trois buts contre
son camp mais enfin tu t'en fous à la
limite tu vois 4 0 et un nul devant le
pauvre dame ça mais c'est tout
est ce que tu penses qu'on veut voir
magnus jouer ouverture complètement
complètement loufoque
ma is à savoir asimo classiques milan et
s'interrogeant le dessin que j'ai deux
projets du petit peu le faire nous qui
sommes pas dans une veine ce soir que
zekri goussé n'a pas tiré les rideaux
fond de sa cave
mais c'est exprès que cha ce point comme
l'a séquestrée pour qu'ils jouent
la principale demande à l'écran c'est je
me demande si georges ils n'ont pas
torturé avant le mc beal soit tu joue ce
match soit tu souhaites tu qu il bon ok
j'y vais mais c'est l'impression qu'ils
donnent les ils étaient séquestrés
pendant trois jours
à manger de d'avoir de l'eau à manger du
pain rassis un sac ouais bien dur il
parle bien durer la mais c'est vraiment
fantastique va te regarder la caméra
beaucoup plus intéressant que vous
regardez les partis assister à la mort
d'un homme
c'est horrible il est complètement au
fond du trou noir mais c'est trop 3h30
franchement tu as chris shaw qui salue
j'arrive c'est quoi le score en vain que
4 0 pour le mot tu as tant qu'acquis
digue à dire en virée qu'il est sur
chatroulette genre si tu vois que good
enough sur chatroulette usa directeur
mais c'est tout à fait ça à ces gens le
truc trash de chatroulette quoi je pense
que je pourrais faire et vous pourrez
avait cette vidéo il joue il joue le
speech championship sur sur pied ce
point comme ce qui suit est incroyable
ce qui arrive est incroyable jusqu'à
l'ailé des chats mâles en fait non va
y'avoir du fou mais quatre qui va
arriver à se faire couler de partout
wyman c'est un grand moment pour ça va
mais pour fait est là pour couvrir vos
des finales arrivée niveau le scénario
qui joue vite pour le moment
bon tu vas prendre 5 faire trop la
boulange
je vais vous montrer surtout reprend 1,5
fou prend qui on prend autour d un toit
de l'atelier un truc à finir comme c'est
fou les deux ouais mais il ya tant pour
le printemps b1 et yappa truite
développement le fils et on garde la
maison elle a fait feu 3 mais là en fait
surtout prend ces trois peut-être ça va
cette finale avec la paire de fou malgré
la structure de pionsat peut aller oui
mais à 5 maintenant jouer le jeu
sérieux j'ai mal pour lui je ne serais
pas dans le genre des gueux pour les
blancs parce que tu fais tout reprend à
deux grands est à l'étude je te
confirmer mais bon on a senti contester
un peu dans les deux premières parties
non on savait qu'ils service qui lui est
arrivé mais tu sais tu y trouves et
l'autre à 4 tu vas te faire encaisser le
pion le ok du scalp à 100% ça va et à la
paire de fou on va voir si jamais le
pion à 5,12 à disparaître c'est quand
même dangereux présents situera qu'elle
va foncer vite fou gedo renfort c'est au
moins ça c'est pas clair table ou quatre
qui dit va se venger sur des petits
milles 2400 après c'est pas faux cela il
peut la tenir pour l'armée de façon il
fera il fera quelques nuls et gagnera
deux trois parties c'est sûr fab
lyonnais s'est jamais arrivé qu'un mec
ça va arriver
en fait nous on a envie que ça arrive
dans wells au bahreïn contre les dames
en fait c'est justement pour que les
gens pensent pas qu'on s'en prenne à
goose et 9 mai c'est la dernière affiche
un peu une intéressante en gros en terme
de niveau de jeu bon c'est cool parce
qu'on va car le cndd joué on a vu des
belles finales et tout s'est vraiment
instructif en fait c'est même
intéressant à regarder mais en terme de
suspense et la dernière affiche vraiment
et on sait déjà qu'il va gagner
en fait l'homme et ses chouchous après
il pourra plus y avoir menem magny je
suis plus contre qui joue au prochain
tour mais c'est pas du 100% déjà sera
contre un mec fort
maxime qualifiés qui le congrès tchouk
éprouve il ya na ka klé las illas auj
il y avait écrit qu'il reste à roanne
s'étaient qualifiés tout cas le jour où
il ya un hic abattu caruana interne a
battu au premier tour s'il est éliminé
on dirait qu'on dépôt oui c'était chaud
donc à défaut sinon il n'y a pas deux
fois encore que magnus contre n'est pas
mon avis c'est la balade mais mais c'est
moins la balade il peut faire une copie
peut battre mais pop art 6 7 points
d'écart même 8 peut-être sais pas mais
il peut pas le fin genre avant le match
je peux pas dire c'est du 100% c'est
georges c'est pas à moi c'est federer ou
peut-être nadal à roland garros contre
un mec bon c'est pas un à bâle contre un
mec bon mais tu sais qu'il va gagner
mais t'es pas sûr à 100% ce socle au
socle des coeurs bon là normalement
quand même je pense pas que vapeur mais
nous pour que ça continue il suffit
qu'ils gagnent pas de parti en fait nous
nul ne le dérange pas trop en fait pas
trop tard mais bon ça nous dérange mais
enfin moyens quand même donc 45 jours et
contre ce au prochain tour donc ok
sautez pas sûr de gagner quand même
après je sais pas où ça lui réussit pas
mal
j'ai pas trop partout en tête ou
d'éternuer on passe de devenir l'année
dernière la partie de ceux qui
voudraient que l'ensemble des cartes et
chèques
c'était à une zone ouais mais justement
il a brigué cdd de trois beaux gosses
bourrés d bien gagner leur bateau tombe
à l'eau on marche au plancher bas ok il
sera gros favoris mais contre sow tu
peux pas dire c'est du 100%
non j'ai pas je pense que c'est 85 90 %
mais pas plus
tu vas pas pareil mais je suis presque
sûr qu'il va le défoncer en fait je
rappelle contre tu te rappelles contre
nac à l'année dernière en finale c'est
il avait été impressionnant c'est ça un
animal en quarantaine non mais pas des
clients finals de londres city ils ont
fini avec ce que vous avec peu de temps
la pendule ils n'ont pas tout
[Musique]
non mais là normalement fait quand même
faut pas abuser tu perds pas ça ok je
comprends l'idée de magnus et du fer g5
tourache un tour g1 et à près de 2 le
révolté mais quand même c'est un but de
toujours le bien est vrai que les blancs
dont tu défends la caisse j en oublie
pas non mais je pense que le problème il
est enfin je m'arrête psychologique
aussi c'est ça la chance je veux que
quelqu'un normal il fait nul en
sifflotant gousseïnov mais la même ça
ils n'arrivent pas à enchaîner les coups
bon alors à un copain 5 pouces et 6 non
plus dû en parler
il avait fait un nul en maths et en
faire nul assez sûr donc tanger deux
coques s'attaquer tout parcours ne va
pas la perdre
panont la perdit peut pas les tours 5 la
juste ouais tu recules le fond l asile
et tu verras ps3 35.8 y avait trois
ouais faut montrer sa donc tour 5 on
peut pas faire x 8 parce que tout retour
huit échecs donc fouet f3 tour f5 pour
chasser le fou est maintenant le fauve
en a huit meilleurs et tour à 5 sur x 8
en plus la même avec 3 bien à ilafy tour
pranger 4 sur tours 5
on n'avait pas vu ça mais je pense pas
que ça change grand chose non seulement
on attend cela dit j fr 3 5 % bref deux
rangées un tour j'ai d'eurofins je pense
que ray on l'avait pas vu ce truc là on
a complètement raté steed est bon mais
on peut pas faire l'agent repousse
quatre fous quelque part et un moment
donné ok mais tour c5 et jean retour
j'ai droit à prêt à le penser
sa petite idée mais mettons a pris 3,63
et tu reviens
ouais et surtour g3 sur foued deux fous
j'ai deux échecs et me revient à wes et
jolie ça en plus foulé cette tour des 5
x 6 tubes à deux corners au québec sq
gousseïnov à un peu de chance là
je vais pas commenter plus avant cela
une chance que magnus lui veut faire
plus de place et je me suis bloqué mon
parrain jean je pense que ça ça ne
l'intéresse pas il veut que ce soit
possible si tu y vas faire on s'en sorte
que ce soit possible
il me va le faire ils peuvent à faire
j'ai q4 la préfecture g3 maintenant et
sur walf de ckoi son idée à monsieur
quatre sets et sur deux nuls mais non tu
prends tu veux h4rem et f6 amis c'est
nul avec mais je te prends et oui oui
oui ça c'est nul on a déjà on en a déjà
parlé
faut pas chercher midi à quatorze heures
même avion un ch-47 nul c'est sûr même
sans le pion à ces immigrés non mais ça
c'est simplissime il suffit juste de
faire pousser un fou fou ici on pourra
jamais jouer f5 f4 ruiz ou là à temps
qu'est ce qui fait baisser jusque fin
comme dirait vlad quand les mecs comment
se faire des trucs bizarres comme ça ça
me fait peur ce qu'il a fait comment
veux tu dois défendre ses pions mais bon
pour la santé d'un point et qui a pas
tellement les vents chauds n'a invoqué
le truc c'est que dès que tu fais f5
on va faire plus on prend tu comprends
et fous des six jeux plus tapées par la
droite qui peut arriver
du coup tombée alors seule course cette
fois face à tant de
de revenir attaquer tu peux faire
pousser cette étude aura le temps de
faire foulée ils ont su ce nom mais
comme dirait vlad en fait c'est juste
que quand tu montres la mauvaise
technique tu donnes envie de jouer en
fait enfin genre normalement si le mec a
pas la bonne technique tu vas de suite
faire nul est ici le mec comment se
faire des trucs comme ça ben t'as envie
de bari ce que tu te dis que mcanuff il
en fait part à concrètement c'est ce que
tu te dis en fait j dilla le mec ne sait
même pas ça bon je pense qu'il connaît
mais c'est juste qu'ils craquent parce
que c'est psychologique en fait donc ce
genre qui veut de vos études mais à sa
demande expresse des caméras et ce deux
fois un très bon dieu le veut ni dans
mon pays je pense que ça l'a salut titi
l'esprit là le bon maintenant il paye la
raison de la pluie il a trouvé perrin
sur l'histoire ok maintenant f4 des
béarnais embellissement tetris pas faire
un petit nul moi mais bon si même ça tu
as du mal à faire nul samedi même si
colonna de ventes et atteint bas mais ça
c'est sûr non mais je dis vraiment ça
dans le sens où voilà ou
psychologiquement ils doivent enfin non
mais c'est jamais agréable de faire
défoncer en plus son public comme ça au
fond de soi internet et machecoul c'est
dur ben non mais bon je vous comprends
donc du coup on a un petit début larsen
boom
je vous en laisse prix on va en fait
chaque ronde il joue un truc et rise of
man 10 jours de l'ouverture des ventes
pas partie ça continue j'habite où il
est très heureux là bas
j'habitais dans le tchat oui et non le
chat un wimille très content je vous dis
tout dépôt exclamations partout dédicace
à bishop btu et magnus éléments et puis
j'habite ou pseudonyme i comme icare
scénarion c'est du 50-50 et je pense pas
un sur un format comme ça y'a trop de
parties saines favori provoquée contre
aronian invivable
je prends ce format salle favorise
vraiment en plus l'un des rares qui peut
l'aider un peu c'est un maxime parce que
faite aux gays et le truc c'est que le
but est d'apaiser la fête très important
est ok maxi il est là oui mais bon
rappelle toi que maxime s'était fait
largement dominé par n'a qu'un but est
département vient juste avant la mue est
il s'était pris plus trop +4 et que
carlson avait dominé gras fnaca mur en
bullet donc mais après après ok comme
d'hab je demande à voir ce truc d'échec
sur un échiquier cas mais c'est un autre
sport sur la seule chose dans les deux
versions enrichies qui a pris la parole
que ni par contre carlson blague cdu
10,90 à peu près à peu près ça mais bon
ce serait trop pénible pour carlson de
jouer ce match en fait on peut ne vaut
on peut pas nous imposer sa vie mais
elle n est pas mal car c'est un bon
toujours dans l'esprit de tous bords
bref cas permis karabakh a émis plus 5
arles c'est long mais il est possible
mais mais il sait pas y avait un truc
dans le match c'est soit qu'il y avait
un gros écart et qu'il avait au final et
après ils avaient lâché la fin ou quoi
mais il avait il avait une grosse avance
et il avait commencé par gagner truc de
bulat et et puis après il a laissé
tomber où je sais plus quoi vraiment de
façon s'il avait envie de le défense en
bullet qui défoncerait il manie de
toujours en vie naka est donc certaine
animosité il va pas le laisser
tranquille je pollue genre désire s en
trois minutes j'ai mis la misère après
il avait un petit peu relâché l'étreinte
bonté de saint-cloud sa ferme et à payer
le synthé jusqu'en mai quelqu'un qui
avait des 5 1 et d'avancer cette date
votre nom dames 5 ça tient tout
peut-être encore peut-être ça tient
encore
peut-être tour des cinq ici un truc
marrant mais il doit pas masquer ces 6
derniers 5 en fait il n'ya plus rien qui
marche
enfin sur un petit marche c'est
important en fait de menacer le fourbe
et cinq au passage à l'efficacité je
suis essayé la pieuvre un argument de
poids pour des new wave on peut pas
essayer de faire dame français trois
prises fou prend ses six essais lors des
grèves il y aurait eu de 4 quand même
bien pour le trou comme le viol
mairal c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
attaquer c'est horrible encore une fois
la prière de retour ne te crache doors
de partout dessus tout un match non mais
c'est vrai puisque c'est un truc
géométriques qui n'est pas à ce qui
arrive pas si souvent ça auquel cas ils
soient pas attaquable je pense d'un f4
bien joué le coup je lui ai proposé
parce que du coup tu peux pas vraiment
chasser la dame avec dame trop dam des
deux skis à la pieuvre emprise est sûr
qu la pieuvre la manche direct léotard à
quatre jours d'un sac du boom sur frans
des 5 et prend des 5 tu dégages suite
fait matin c'est cette amérique dames 5
to la dame alors espace france a calé
des cinq est jamais sûr qu'il va perdre
un processeur arm a appelé au nom n'a
pas vu ce matin a raté le flou à ce que
l'objet ria tours 8 curan curan la
qualité vous
la première gamme de la soirée pour
magnus
ok
par la sic
dommage j'adore avec moi il avait traité
le truc bloquer ses gammes plaisir qu'il
ait fait une gaffe pour vous c'est une
oeuvre parce que je vois chez lui il
sait il est tellement au fond du trou
bon après évidemment on a envie qui perd
de tout mais enfin tu vois ça mais bon
on fait feu sur lui c'est un peu de
baume au coeur quand même failli malades
d'être haute en pls qu'avant
enfin ça a pas l'air de l'avoir en fait
pas un peu choqué et 20h tu gap son coup
et aurait donc pu te prends des cinq
planètes ne prend en compte que jamais
après ça marche pas bizarre et je suis
en france et ça c'est pas la même
histoire des cinq une forme de tueurs en
sifflotant séparément enfin bon tiens
damage de bien jouer 1
l'armée saleh va peut-être la gagner
mais j'espère qu'il va esquisser un
sourire car m6 gagne la ligue à dire un
sourire lille a encore rien de faire un
pataquès déploie son idée à 5 à 6 des
machins non mais c'est sûr qu'il a pas
encore gagné mais la pire reste elle n'a
pas le soutien logistique avec elle mais
elle est là elle peut cracher de granger
de partout quand même les caméras sont
des cas il ya quelqu'un qui arrive et il
a tout fait décaler sur le truc de zoom
c'est daniela va pas regarder ce moment
il va revenir mais c'est daniel qui a
tout décalé avec seulement ce monde j'ai
parlé ce que tu pense qu'il va thème la
gagner il n'y a plus de stream anglais
d'ailleurs penser après tout vent sur le
stream français allez on se bat ou de la
pub à d'ailleurs avant de vous si vous
partez sur les réseaux sociaux tout ça
comme d'hab je n'ai pas envie de stream
donc forcément la moins de monde et je
connaisse - mais où on l on est conduit
2 200 de 165 par la ce est persuadé à
500 peut-être un truc comme ça
r je sais pas combien d'études
supérieures sur bitstream lâchez pas
jeter bas pour le prêt live et bien fait
se prendre un cavalier 17 bien senti un
caïd et cette échelle je sens bien qu'il
prend des cinq la faa a tu peux pas
reprendre le ksk dame prend à chuter des
menaces de qualité cet échec j'ai peur
qu'ils se fassent machine à gagner
non mais a choisi le plus de temps la
pure ne peut me vient de partout peu
n'ya pas se faire ma tête du cac et
prend à 6 échecs a lancé en vain des
princes hisse sa femme c'est fini je
crois et c'est simple dames à 107 km et
5 maintenant voilà briser cette force
c'est son nom va progresser mais après
on assez pauvre il va parti pour bombe à
damas à tour ces cinq hommes tomber
cette non plus comme ça
alors attends qui s'est même tour 5
d'autres fins ici quel type il minimise
touté kalé là c'est horrible n'importe
quoi qu'en dise alors dit moi c'était
très bien qu est ce que vous faites là
quoi maintenant on à daniela règne sur
le stream le d'autres atouts la loi du 4
au 5
ps tu défends plus est cet étrange jeu
c'est dur on peut tomber bombe et l'a
placée c'est le football a une forme de
taxe est terminée ben perdre celle là
c'est quand même difficile
psychologiquement c'est un gros coup sur
le stream anglais on distille à 13 mi
mai et beaucoup de gens qui regardent
les stream en anglais quand il ya un
magnus parce que en fait et norvégiens
sont bilingues et les échecs sont très
populaires en norvège ça ajoute
énormément de monde en fait nous ce
qu'on ya maxime qui a plus de monde
la minus une star mondiale au canada
quasiment une scandinave hybride au
final ces personnes qui avaient dit que
ce money bank and améliorée je pense pas
que sur les meilleurs trucs qu'il est ni
dans sa vie en fait non mais t'as raison
de le citer mais géré par la ce je pense
que c'est pas tu vois dans les citations
qu'il a fait des murs et les niveaux la
drogue c'est la vie pas le gras c'est
l'avis de grâce à vis et karadoc qui
passe tu connais non le niveau camelot
tu n'étais pas bon je suis fait je suis
pas experte en vue que de l'eau chaude
en plus on voit pas bien léo st john the
big beauty vivement que vous pensez de
goussé nord va sortir un livre sur la
psychologie de ces chèques set méritant
un pouce jeu pour plus tard la gagne m'a
vraiment fait très cher les c5 typique 1
pour se libérer dans ces structures car
au canon
puis au passage on a attaqué le centre
et la case de cinq noms mais bon contenu
risque de change étroitement les cas on
rencontre les pièces de kent s'est de
suite tu attends 966 aura plus de chance
ces neuf encore vous alors pas juste
faire qualifier si cela se développer ou
tard et bourg non mais la sphère grand
roc ou petit rock ses parts au québec
pas ok bon allez on va vous faire rêver
c'est à cette chance qu'un seul je
n'étais pas devant déséquilibré avec eux
sinon techniquement aucune chance mais
finalement aucune chance d'engranger des
th 5 quotidiens problème en fait
nettement mieux mais bon je vous
cherchez toujours de trucs du genre de
scénarii h 15 voilà le suggérer watch
trois vainqueurs - 15 50 affiche deux
très bien le moment on le vend
et voilà la carte c'est non sans fil en
difficulté suite il doit y est maniable
même s'il est en difficulté à changer un
peu sa routine pas positivement juste
technique tu as montré que ces quinze
années mon parcours il s'était lui aussi
s'est ouvert donc à l'école il n'y a pas
et pas de grandes méthodes miracles par
un truc une personne ce qu'on fait nous
en fait on ne joue pas contre lui fait
tout bêtement pas si tout le monde
refusé de jouer contre lui ferez quoi
car la scène je ne veux pas jouer contre
m'intéresse pas tu as beau être champion
du monde et champion de riom personnes
de jouer contre toi
alors là on fait comment c'est peut-être
ça en fait la vraie technique lensois ne
jouerait plus personne ne joue c'est
fini le jeu n'existe plus il joue aux
échecs non c'est un peu comme dans men
in black ii flesh le
des espaces se passe dans men in black
pas dans men in laquelle sept ans le
petit truc de mémoire la de stylos et de
flash tout le monde oublie le nom le jeu
d'échecs
sauf lui il arrive je veux jouer à ce
jeu ne nous intéresse pas mais bon là il
a fait petit rock avec hk t-il encore
plus dans l'esprit que ce qu on se
pensait mais le truc c'est qu'il va se
prendre du g5 à un moment donné qui va
tout lui ouvrir faisais ma soeur qui
nantes qui le demandent combien on
donnerait pour jouer contre lui mais moi
je ne veux pas jouer contre eux enfin
m'intéresse non je jouais bien je
dormais pas pendant trois heures comme
ça tu vois j'ai 5
il écoute en plus le stream ça y est on
a compris ceux qui goûtent avec les
écouteurs en fait non mais j'ai cinq
bien joué un bien beau mais alors attend
qu'ils avaient prend 17 intermédiaire
mais ajusté leur tour prend 17 non on
s'en fiche pages comment on va en fait
bon ok tu prends des z voilà je reprends
ils dopent sont des six
on va reprendre et puis après jour à
alger une quatre roues mais peut-être
que faire qu'il prend des 4 à la fin
pour essayer de se débarrasser un peu de
ses pièces proches de son roi mais enfin
il faut jouer des trucs comme ça va
assez bien joué de la part de goussé
enough
la seule chance c'est que je me rate les
lieux la partie d'avant avec avec le
clouage la nouvelle miss a raté lui même
ça c'était pas suivre ouais enfin c'est
vraiment dur un nom circule pas dire des
huit peut-être référence peut-être cinq
ans même où j'ai capté prochain
j-4 carrieu 5t pour lutter pour ses
seules d'abord de quoi mon école ça soit
garde quand même un peu toujours qu'ils
louent ou b5 pas mal peut-être fou prend
ses six cavaliers simple dans le bon
tempo était donné mais peut-être cette
dame cinq dames 5 fab lab et ça aurait
été pas mal parce que cinq jours elana
mais lecavalier
je veux il veut plus voir finalement
jamais cessé sa force et l'échangent de
dames en fait beaucoup plus vous et au
moins tu reprenait de d'études et
doublette enfin tu débarrasser du pur
isolé et tout mais bon c'est ce qui fait
la beauté de pression à position il
était moins bien et je bats toi que
c'est pas vraiment rêver mais bon c'est
le cas et qu'il arrive en f4 lors dé
tels de magda nasa d'eric du cavalier de
la colonne h tu adores cavaliers f4 je
laisse déjà peut-être tour c'est un
ouais mais notre région ses revenus pour
les mains j'ai eu un petit espoir aux
énormes l'espace d'un instant c'est
qu'il m'arrive en f4 petit à petit nom
il veut pas le cas f4 pour le moment
c'est il commence à s'approcher avec ces
pièces là
en plus s'ils jouent hyper vite
la pta epson g4 pour ces deux qui est le
cas et c'est ce que tu pense qu'il
devrait y avoir un chaos dans ces matchs
de ce pitch est ce genre si tu sais trop
défoncé tu perds parc à août
ben oui le mec qui peut te dire je pas
venu ici pour souffrir ok merci c'est
aux rimes et enfin c'est beau à voir
comment comment tu mènes contumace à mai
86 26 50
non mais ça impressionnant fab labs et
surtout le lot où va la force des gens
comme ça ils ont besoin de faire valoir
de temps en temps pour montrer à quel
point ils sont forts en fait c'est à
dire le 111e joueur mondial 26 47 et qui
est bon en guise donc dans le bild
ambitieux a largement et dans le top 100
mondial rempli ce sont les leafs et 26
94 et son îlot rapide
fi donc 27-14 annoncé un jour du top
tsonga l'an 800 rapide et juste en train
de se prendre une leçon non tu as
l'impression que c'est un cas d en face
n'est plus un mec assez talentueux des
grands maîtres à 16 ans tu mettras 14
nous aimons vie de serre
un perron unis peut-être qu'à plus ils
disent on pourrait considérer que le
match est fini mais en fait je pense
qu'il a raison il devrait y avoir une
limite de points paquin ce pas
d'ailleurs avec mon jouet pour des
petits amis de 7,02 perdu en 11 ans
fanny soul c'est vrai qu'ils adorent
fait c'était juste une vrai que vous
avez inventé vous en fait ça n'a aucun
rapport avec quoi que ce soit de réel
non mais bon 17 02 souvent barré du
trophée tout grand espoir le bon wagon
mich et réfléchie prend son temps et que
vous êtes faire f4 là quand même parce
que mon rêve
sa fiche au f4 cavaliers c4as
l'intermédiaire mais l'a juste prix il a
dû juger cette finale vers quoi 3 et par
la cour des genres tout choisi un autre
truc en tête dans la f3 de tanger quatre
tours 2-3 elle soit 30 des cas très peu
de la porte derrière ce qu'on tournait
encore regagné il ya un peu plus de deux
semaines
ouais ça là sans tracas soit gagnant
mais quand j'ai peut-être
de witte autorités pour jésus n'a pas le
temps de faire f 7 et de ramener son
aide pour que je n'aie pas peur des gens
écoutent le plus cette france de
rejoindre mon club a une
en fait je pense de lui soumettre le
pion à vii et qui ont tué à le prendre
il va prendre des 5 et la finale de
pions elle est ingagnable avec les noirs
mais bon je pense que des plats
norvégien mais je pense que il capable
quand même de la perte du sénat -
n'échappe peut-être voulait pas laisser
des cas trois des cinq mais bon ça à pas
grand chose
je n'aime pas trop ce qui va laisser
faire b5 les deux pions pas c'est bon
c'est nul mais ted bsi souffre peut-être
après le roi l'ifi les pions électrique
machin je sais pas ce genre sont debout
série nascar et peut-être faire je pense
qu'il est fait roi prend le hockey même
un roi des 6,3 aussi suivi reprendre le
pion 1
ortiz a marqué dans mes classes font
construire trois options leader ça finit
d'arrêt alors je répète pour les gens
qui arrivent sur le stream vous avez le
score à gauche des noms donc puisque ses
cinq et demi pour magnus carlsen est un
demi point pour gus et enough
pour mme anissa vuvuzelas nul à accepter
mais non mais non ça c'est george szell
lui une sorte on a droit devant lyon ils
n'ont pas progressé
on a évidemment une de nos masters iv ou
v pour collectif qu'on organise le
prochain c'est qu'en 17 et le lendemain
c'est un 17 2 2 tonnes nous intéresser
bon là on l'appelle alliance dans les
vidéos qu'on fait d'habitude sur
bitstream la chaîne youtube où les
allées et et voilà sinon des sites vidéo
au pluriel échec une ville échec encore
une petite veste aliens lorsque de luxe
des mags 10 h 4 g kg sont avoués trois
fontaines hockey cinq ans j'aurais
simulation ses cseries
là on joue comme on l'a fait avec les
blancs las vegas
dommage il adore rester sur des cinq
états qu il ya six moniteurs des cinq
leaders le genre truc l'une des dents de
quoi capter 10 600 score de tennis à des
points moi je t'ai pas pour cela la
raison que j'aime bien que les normes
j'ai pas je fais pour qu'il dise toute
annonce est tu remets en cause la
manière de vue de ma guise non mais en
même temps il veut pas d'un truc publié
condor j'ai reçu en le palais pétition
et être à l'aise
il ya des simples la colonne des fr
c'est ça qui les deux décès car tout ça
mais bon il était noir ce thème de
qu'est lancé 5 pts 5 f kg assez simple
quand même jeu game 5 pages c'est pareil
à 2,5
le gaillard se fait nada lisez ça que ça
ressemble le match contre nadal en fait
dans le style des non échangées en fait
t'as jamais aucune chance de gagner
moindre échange dégage 5 savourer de
regarder quel âge 5 ces cinq cas il
prend ses 5 qui est des cinq qui ont
grand calife vous proférez compilable
états d'âme c'est cette loi aura tant
qu'amis et 58 non c'est 5 c5 guérissent
et 5 à bria qui tourne bien mais ça
marche pas ça mais parce que qu'elle ait
trempé des cinq puis on prend les cinq
ces français 5 enfilade états d'âme
c'est ça l'important d'organisation je
suis plein de vide
ok la crise et 5 je pense mais il
passait jusqu'à ce que tu veux mais là
tu vas pas chassé par b 4e 6 405 est ok
maintenant par meta toujours tu peux pas
te barrer facilement acquis et les docks
et ses 4 je sais pas c'est pas clair
pourquoi tu peux qu on s'affaire du même
geste de médecin inclus d'année 6,5
toujours en poche mais un match sans
qu'un cabinet g5 gk comme ça très
barbare
et après ce que les français
s'inquiètent pas jouable en tennis
dingue pourquoi pas qu'il pense et ça ça
me semble la personne à 9,6 lorsqu'il
france 3 où kenny do j'imagine que je
fais des cas pas séparables bon ça là il
peut peut-être la gagne ok gagner je
sais pas mais il est une partie oui ce
pays mais les pièces peut jouer vite et
wade ses droits c'est dans ce genre
d'incertitude que tu as tes chansons il
est très à l'aise que je vous êtes tard
dans la semaine par ailleurs faire des
preuves pour changer les dates des
finales je comprends mais je suis
retrouvé avec notamment quatre échecs et
j'ai jamais trouvé prête pour les dents
là dessus qu'il prénom age 3 à la fac
qui est proche 3,43 n'est pas si faible
je vais te fermes avec une option s'est
passé qui est des sanguinaires mais
maintenant tu as honte que je ex
d'amnesty c'est tout t'as pas le choix
sachez qu'il allait prendre h3 en fait
et faire un maître le four en g2 qui
veut faire qui est des cinq à venir en
aide mais tout est dit qu'à draguer donc
y jouer devant des quatre d'un match qui
a péché je suis fait prendre les quatre
et qui protégerait les atours d'un match
4 échecs donc juste pour montrer la dame
qui a attaqué il ya la tournée dans le
vis-à-vis qui est prend des cas de
protéger la tour mais le temps de faire
d'un match 4 échecs la silhouette un peu
forcée voilà le choix tu prends le fric
et qui arrive en d5 quand même je sais
vous peuples des trois
et s'il vous sinon je suis pas resté
dans la voiture des trois jeux sont à
prendre
oui certains il opère et on fout hein
maintenant matériellement on en est où
dans cette partie égalité matérielle
rigal et gagnent mais quelqu'un est
mieux ou pas il est bon dans machete de
magicien
majeur h quatre personnes quand même
j'ai pas su contrôler un peu le pion
leucate on sait jamais il a 15 3 est-ce
que j'ai trois c'est si bon tout à fait
me cale un peu les cartes blanches en
fustigeant la découpe quoi bon dès le
départ des trois même genou n'est pas
rien
le clip cinq interprètes en mai c'est
dieu qui fait les dangers du change pas
les uns des logis larzac ça semble pas
mal mais sur des médecins qui veut
peut-être faire du fou j'ai 2 f 4 5
après free pour mai 2010 dans une
analyse critique et cousines a fait une
meilleure position possible tarder à
mettre 4 je ne veux pas de ces dames sur
l'échiquier magnus unis dégagent les
dames ne m'intéresse pas c'est passé pas
les pièces qui m'intéresse
mais en prime c'est que mme hussein fils
est mal autant plus
ça promet pour la suite têtu pour le 3 +
2 le machin web moyens je crois pour la
cua bah oui enfin c'était ironing d'un
look et bien perdre confiance on faisait
les mains porter à balayer la la je
pense que c'est son son niveau ii conçu
de confiance fait c'est même par niveau
de confiance en fait ils menacent
peut-être dam des six dames 5 a lieu
sept qui est ici si ce qui forcerait
tout reprend et le pion ans baisserait
pas mal passé bien sûr la colonne des
géants comme il serait encore plus dur à
arrêter avec les carriers ans et 6 anna
adenon il nous propose un changement de
joueur au monde peut pas le ballon mais
bon tu mets nakache est battu mais
quelqu'un en face pour arrêter
l'hémorragie
dommage qu'il paye mamediarov d'heure
dans ce tournoi je pense qu'on était
forts une usine neuve qui a de nouveau
disparu
du coup le voit ils se cachent ils vont
encore bon chose un bide
il attendait que ces pièces oui tout est
horrible
un tour en tiendrons à 5 avait encaissé
un but en plus non mais là c'est sûr que
les échanges
est ce que tu penses qu'il fait comme
l'entraîneur de rugby de l'équipe
d'algérie
j'en ai plein les couilles de perdre il
en peut plus c'est surtout non plus jugé
suffit encore de l'équipe j'ai pas
gagner un match ça me fait trop mal et
j'ai re regarder ya pas si longtemps
qu'elle a peut-être le bus je lui fous
h3c huit tours à 5 3
peut-être plus un tenant de personnes il
ya plus simple
cava le 3 5 17 qu'avec des 3 5 17 ou un
truc comme ça
cette fois je crois quand même pour
empêcher ou 17
et puis après ramener le calme vers 17
en fait c'est très très très déprimant
mais pour pour gagner la caméra était
temps à vraiment à rennes je me
souvenais réparer in the north et vous
n'auriez rien de toute façon montre une
burn alpha qui dit que pour des livres
agilia khelifi stream public
tiens moi je suis la reine est mort à
dire très patient et dégage avec tes
pièces
ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne joue pas je
refuse de jouer le rebond à l'hémorragie
tout de suite arrêté en fait notre
petite allumette aussi sera tressée qui
ne met absolument rien gousseïnov avec
s'en fout non non il ya toujours sept 7
1 face à le mans à vannes l2 où il nous
plaît à risques est ce que ça voilà les
vrais échecs
est-ce que ça peut favoriser à jour
azéri bah oui faut bâtir des gens que je
veux jouer et faire péter le monde sait
qu'il ya des patients non d'hésitation
plus des seuls à tout prix faire à 5,5
direct que sur quels points 5 à double
attaque
je pense aux cinq angles aux ados mesure
déjà dans ma news comme d'hab
une bande de potes tranquille un but à
la fin il est là orange est ce que ma
gni sans caméra parce que gaillard n'est
plus là alors
mes cousins chez adam szalai
20 minutes les nus s'il veut pouvoir
peut-être échange de même bientôt la
finale dames 6 pas mal il développe sa
dame est d'amener devant mais on a sévi
tu vas faire du des six est un cavalier
a vite souffert garde quand même pour y
revenir un jour en direct est une chose
qui doit revenir
bon c'est vrai qu'on sait pas ce que
peut être on décèle normand espère on
espère il peut marquer ses premiers
points avant de lancer six points de vue
qu'elle me vient des arbres
ouais calme les ardeurs en tant
qu'espace pas surtout un homme pas d'un
grand c2 et tu vas manger tout ça
impunément le front des trombes au
propre ou au caire en fait c'est dans
cette honda l'insurrection
la leaf dit non moi je pense aux joues
larves et après on connaît ma citation
et tout s'arrête et toute ma philosophie
non mais attends mais c'est tout mais je
crois pour aller prendre un pion sur la
ici on fait juste fou des deux georges
eux mêmes ont fondé deux tâches pas des
repas ouais et a pas assez d'activités
pour un patron d'eygalières élu l'a
compris il a compris la vraie stratégie
des échecs ça ils peuvent peut-être que
c'est le retournant la situation
les pions ne sont que des miettes de
pain jeté à la figure de l'adversaire et
il prend les pions et dimanche picore
picore et c'est sa bande jarret grosse
erreur de magnus avec 1,33 pions ou les
pièces c'est de la merde aussi peut-être
qui la font là non mais quelle idée 4
allez-vous marina un tour c'est un sais
pas tu te bats on les vide des six va
aussi ckfd 5 souhait difficile il va
vous foutez pas photo
cependant c'est quoi la médaille c'est
une pièce un pion de moins c'est quoi il
faut que les pions qu'on peut iliad un
premier acquis par ailleurs mais que
vraiment les pions sur les conseillers
tout match le dal pour d'autres ce que
ça donne des soins lessard de suffire
large aux non abonnés à des menaces matt
lettre k relief cette maintenant à toi
tu as étudié le dessin qu'il aurait misé
dépens de problème ce ne pas trop
magique et s'étendre depuis que reculer
piouf cotorep et se fait tour à 3 allée
fou prend un peu pour elle on est ce que
je vais faire un père peut être tour à
trois tours b 3 es tu pars de la série
que la dame ce quatrième set mais je
peux pas mamie à rien j'ai l'impression
en fait de coton avec des fantastiques
on descend au rayon que je
donc et ses quatre mille menace rien
malheureusement maintenant de diego
mutombo récurrente du roi des preneurs
c'est sa part des huits 3,7 ou même
peut-être f 4 1 et contre attaque à
trois des huit jeunes surfeurs cette pie
vii 3e 8 mai bruit rauque d'ailleurs il
y avait bougé son roi ou pas ils aillent
là il avait reçu d'un emploi il est
alors que faire petit roy qui aurait pu
oublier d'ailleurs ça sur un coup qui
s'oublie ça maintient que des trésors
sur un peu évangélique au genou droit de
vie ou de mort quand tu vas faire flouer
7 la main tendue 1 oui oui ça rit
fawcett trop vite faire gaffe 26 oui
j'ai vu du fossé des tribus locales 6-3
6-3 6-7 3/7 3,8 c'est nickel non c'est
nickel pour pour les noirs cette
histoire
penser gagner un yahoo via 0 tactique y
a rien c'est fini c'est marc encore
beaucoup de consolidation est pas
vraiment une finale ça va faire comme
cher 1 8 1 re au dessus lors des cats
home a reçu l'ancien même cavalier cédé
5 la main rotation de l'accueil pour le
côté rock 120 vignes à ce défi tu as pu
saboter les pions et l'amf allusion mais
qui a connu contrat catherine 3f qui est
méchant
sa défense est malheureux
malheureux le joueur le jour à 0 face à
faire plus est chez pas est-ce qu'on va
arriver un je pense qu'on va se prendre
un record ce soir je bats c'est quoi
encore c'est carrément un coup ou
peut-être thabo massa ces gens puissent
14 quelque chose comme ça en record mais
je pense que les +14 +15 +16 on allait
dépasser fable - record historique le
corps du monde un peu les 9 58 le but
c'est une bombe
bah non mais bon taf c'est tout le match
qu'on allait revenir aux gens il ya des
mecs qui parlent azéri dans le chat de
tête les dégager en fait ainsi continuer
alors là on n'est pas là pour l'algérie
non plus un tauren petrossian c'était
peut-être le record mais je crois que ça
a été légalisé en fait j'ai eu des
matches j'aurai avec le même score
ah tiens ces techniques eric et prend
les quatre pages web
du coup c'est différent les pions qui
avance des marches à relent d'enchères
lensois bouchons il ya peut-être dû à
peut-être tiré ça nul ne peut pas faire
tourner des côtes de galice et 4 1 segan
bassin d'un marchand lors des 5e le font
bien mieux avec 38 défend l'enceinte
étudieront plus rien tombé 2-4 bah oui
mais c'est ça en fait c'est qu'il ya des
fourchettes de partout tu pouvais plus
le défendre en fait et sur un sujet j'ai
vu un article aujourd'hui un mec qui
théorisent et ça apparemment ils ne
cherchent pas en quatre ans ils pensent
eux quatre cavaliers ça gagne pour une
meilleure force très très intéressant
comme recherche
il a aussi analysé ils pensent que
quatre cavistes doit gagner contre
autour des questions médicales mouais
mais tu as fait deux fois ta qualité de
tuiles hull quoi les non moins dans les
dépenses que dans ton salon fin annoncée
des chèques mais je comprends pas parce
que du coup si tu as deux tours qu'on
soit 4 car il s'est forcément nul ah oui
tu veux faire tout en complétant pour
khalid jamaï de se faire baptiser
je sais pas ce qu'il fait mais comment
tu peux faire est obligé j'ai pas du gp
oui mais c'est le mec le plus haut à
21,30 machin ou à ce qu'il ait jamais
cassé ça a tellement eu une vie très
intéressante a presqu'autant que le
match mais bon je sais j'ai vu ça j'ai
pas voulu ça tout est là mais bon j'ai
fait partager a du coup vu qu'on
m'aiderait très intéressante aujourd'hui
non mais c'était 21,4 contre carl c'est
une pétition un peu désolé du spectacle
quelque part c'est trop facile mais bon
on n'y peut rien c'est prochain tour
sera forcément fusée intéressant contre
sow ce sera ce sera chaud mais là
malheureusement ce match là quid flight
versus quynh trang alors une superbe
image in game mix pertes avec trotski
sitting de sibérienne forest analyse une
after tonight wasa kings format can
always been the king chris quinn prof
hassiane j'aime à penser iqbal
s'attisent et y composent heures j'ai
pas vraiment fait il a un super hormis
le mec pour vous résoudre le truc à fond
quand il dit que pour avaliser une
semaine et voilà
il y avait treize mille spectateurs donc
si vous venez dépasser dix mille ses
besoins et perdu pas mal au passage quai
des bulles mailly sur la chaîne en
anglais mais très possible ce qui avec
magnus n'est plus en plus maintenant il
ya un partenaire j'espère comme avec
twitch et donc ils sont en première page
de twitch en anglais le craignent
beaucoup de monde mais en fait j'avais
perdu pas mal de spectateurs un moment
donné il faut compter de midi mamadou
sylla il a changé il a mis un pull quoi
swag soit donc comme çi push presqu'île
amis chose soit le double que musique
jeune homme c'est un budget star
peut-être wes imagine
avec une capuche et ou non mais je suis
un peu désolé pour glisser enough money
vraiment le mec il est revenu s'asseoir
reyes même plus sélectionner la région
de son image passé horrible ne
sélectionne pas me la semaine fut
sélectionné pourra récupérer le visage
de boucé 9 cyrus et liam a les couilles
qui ne voudrait pas plutôt un
commentaire sur le zéro victor noir dans
le dernier stockfisch ouzzine pur sang
partout bon gré j'étais pas au courant
bah je sais pas d où le blanc smur
quadeurs plus j'ai pu remettre les
caméras un truc c'est que si magnus
continu continu continu comm sa
s'il a fait plus cette la tiens ça
repart déjà appelé on vous dit que soit
donc comme cheap nike l'attention alors
là ton contrat avec vista pourquoi je
peux la partie a repris sa reprise a
repris sa joue là rien de tout cela
chips des gros jobs désole un gilet
c'est juste un tout petit peu la clim
spéciale pour l'ordinateur pour le
refroidir un tout petit peu sans qu'on
n'ait pas de coupure donc vous devez
avoir un petit bruit de leurs réseaux
d'eau qui est peut-être un poil
désagréable mais ça va ça va pas durer
très longtemps gelé 5,5 10 minutes pour
vous aider dans l'avion temps forts
ouais non mais enfin c'est juste que
sinon est ce qu'on risque c'est juste le
crash total caméras chez toi marie n'est
pas le bronx à tapas tard donc ok
système unique de langue anglaise donc
c'est ce triangle vers le bas donc avec
les blancs contre d'autres souches pour
avis cadre du programme brigade
g bâle à n'importe quel coût de pommes
tombées 1
je croise au large tranchée je pense
m'être bien mais je vais faire b4 direct
c'est pas au parlement
peut-être tarifs 4 sur vigueur ça c'est
pas un peu mal prendre 24 heures
la ville a pris du fou n'a pas payé
kipré réductions et des quatre pans du
four si notre histoire où est ce que ça
nous mène 16 soit pas de même des
clément tu veux pour décathlon ou 3d
galles des quatre maintenant
ouais il était venu un jour moi lors des
cadeaux avant saison et il prépare en
tout cas maintenant des quatre équipes
qui nous demandaient des quatre équipes
on est pas aux questions mais en fait
une nouvelle fois j'aime bien la
position debout ses notes là pour le
moment ce que dame 3 c'est pas folichon
folichon
c'est pas trois pattes à un canard ou
qu'ils réussissent parages où il attaque
le fou aucun cas où mais yvette points à
sa fiche
je n'ai pas kevin les pions aux pommes
matters c'est choquant même peuple
m'adore bonnet de pomme s'est pas dit
non mais il dit peut-être chez passe il
parle il est qu'il parle couramment gré
c'est sûr c'est pas si ça ne parlant
norvégiens ont passé pas en norvège en
fait à quel point il parle norvégien à
quel point ils parlent vrai dans le
groupe mais parle quand même beaucoup
anglais on le reverra le
[Musique]
après ça fait marrer l'accent français
je scénarise il faut à lille et 120 pays
parlent anglais comme en français qu
genre comme moi il aime beaucoup et il
est moqueur attention
bon ok malaga dire pour le moment il se
bat pas mal quand il va faire pions
français 5 va contre attaquer sur
detroit il ya peut-être le pion f2 dans
le visage on pouvait parfois c'est
toulalan de lacq odyssée de terrassement
si toi tu me 17 mai oui non je suis la
pression dans le rock et même c'est
d'aller dire on protège tout pour le
moment et on ira choper des 3l souffre
ou non mais regardez lille
ils sont le 4 1 pour prendre deux
premiers tours elle devrait mais à ce
stade juste bien pour les noirs ça c'est
peut-être là on est on est est en train
de vivre une victoire de ghazir là les
torts mais nous avons trop bas je ne
connais pas
bon qui s'épanche ont le droit donc
formation tortue pour terrain face au
mélange il faut prendre deux ce serait
une erreur je pense qu'on ferait dame
prend 1,2 et ongles indret un peu non
quoique peut-être dam des cartes enfin
deux variantes double hatami échelle
ouais mais royal 7
ouais mais du coup je reviens fois je
suis peut-être chez pas je veux pas
c'est mieux on va perdre mais te fait
roi h7 là avec les normes rush cette
jeune maman pour faire potiche déficit
sous la barre des vite les trucs les
échecs son amitié à bhl s'était etc
la digital bros achète humain est
peut-être le fou prend e dan des quatre
d'ailleurs allé là bas il est trop dans
l'esprit en fait il des couteaux ont
tour à tour à 8,3 chef sioui à foyen
ayoub l'année mais peut-être même dame 4
le baril est super soit l'idée c'est de
faire rager cet etf us et 5 en fait moi
pas constat majeur quand même bien
commencé tout ça parfois achète en
premier en fait trois sets un premier
pardon
et ce fou et 317 j'imagine mais impose
un travail à faire froid g2 et il va
venir encaissé le cinq plus tard les
menaces même phare wager 21.5 ces
menaces quand même même cette dame prend
25 direct c'est possible et que faisait
5 qui reste en prise aux reflets bien
contenir mes choix juste faire rager 2
et prendre les prend 2,5 à sa son magnus
je pense qu'il va être du tout intéressé
par le fait de faire une nulle un bon ce
match je pense que copilote le fond on
doit annuler pour toi c'est quelque
chose
bon mais difficile d'attaquer encore
plus le pion non me plaît mais moi j'ai
deux occupent les lieux une fois c'est
qu'après tu leur dis mais la norme ce
proche de ces lieux trois ex fc baraka
toi il ya le 4 qui fut prend enfin le 2e
dan prendre soin de mon projet de paix
du monde
québec adq rendait quatre mains et le
port de hambourg rêvent du show car je
peux croire l'enquêté juste orifices
pour protéger le pion g6
et on veut revenir avec le fond ans et
cinq au prochain
namasté tous pour gagner la victoire
s'avère bien manger 2 on y trouve par
être trahi à battre angers 1 pas s'il y
trouve des recettes mots et il va il pas
mettre en place ces trucs là tout va en
russie ce duke ouais j'ai choisi ma
échanger les tours et faire flouer
quatre là je souffrais tellement c'était
bien fait parce qu'ils passent avant
d'attaquer le plonger ici c'est tout
elle a laissé passer sa chance
il va prendre prend des progressistes et
sur des problèmes de dame prend airways
france pour h5 ça ne rentre pas dans la
finale ivey mauvais jours enfin pas tout
à poser nos bas c'est ça
bon mais on va dire que ces quelques
petites nul est sûre l'équipe miche de
pain un championnat prend c'est à petit
scout d'eau dans le désert quoi la
petite poire dose une petite goutte
jacky lasvaux lui c'est pas le désert
c'est une car apparemment trop évident
c'est que le rayon de soleil dans la
cave du coup
eric comme ça ne sais pas ce qu'il se
passe sur le stream en anglais les gens
qui parlent pas beaucoup à 6 à m'en
parler
si je regarde un peu ce qu'ils font sur
les 4000 tard que suri 4 arrive à kamal
ces jeux comme sur le sénat fait je
sentais sur les 4 mais non sachons
daniel cohen qui a une certaine tu as
une certaine autorité tu vois tu sens
que heather demain il ya un gros match
et ce point comme on commentera pas ben
fine gueule contre saimone williams 1 ça
ça serait ça aurait été plus marrant de
commenter ça en fait que le match qu'on
commet comme un vent d'air bel et bien
les trucs vous voulez wifi on s'est
serré pas la même c'est pas séries tu te
marque
marseille mène la bonne bière peut bien
au pied de choquer mais en fait je sais
pas s'il faut le commenter ce match vous
laisser le mec par les vagues saimone sa
mini gros match je lui dis rien oui
crise je suis pas aimer l'amérique fait
ce qu'il veut tlj thaddée segard le
match salman et ben je sais pas ne va
pas le commenter donc je sais pas je ne
suis pas vraiment occupé de ça mais mais
tu peux regarder sur chaque point comme
demain ils écriront ça doit être à peu
près à la même heure je pense les
connaissances ou est à la même heure il
aime bien regarder la le même les mêmes
horaires ils ont raison d'ailleurs ou
pas connus ou non avec nous on a une
chance pour la finale surtout je te dise
et calmement le moins intéressant de la
compétition donc on va on va changer le
toit
donc voilà c'est espagnol mais il
continue donc structuration un nouvel
élan au laisser-faire la majorité ni
mort ni blessé n'a contesté à droite
pasqua chercher un fief pro f 5
voilà les éleveurs à oui tu prends deux
en premier chez sfr ont pu le prendre
vous voulez ça c'est une option
[Musique]
la bcc bien non et jacques gautier sur
les tours camionnage normalement je sais
pas s'il est enfin c'est une option dont
des petites subtilités de l'art de rien
il devance haute récompense de lavage
des hausses à venir en fait peut-être
c'est tout rage ça tousse et 1
j'ai pages avancé personnel pour les
blancs c'est le fallait nos pas trop de
contre indications coloris lorient 2 1
il est les gens racontent à cette
structure telle joie tel droit de passer
à terme ces normes ne pas taire vraiment
que vous sautez donc palpable ces sites
us les lords bloqué mettre un avocat
véreux ou pas toujours été bien fixe
trois attaques étaient pions et c'est
plus la même mayonnaise mais que vous
n'avez pas un peu de tout ça aurait
peut-être saint cloud
ça a l'air pas mal mais il faut qu'il
joue un peu plus vite là faut pas qu'ils
se mettre trop mal autant on enlève le
lundi 20 juin
mais 2,5 peut-être tu attaques ont été
des quatre départs au sein du giec et
les gars je vais pas prendre une
fourchette il ya tanase québec 3,35 en
l'air faites un truc comme ça 87 6 db
trois fois ci sur lui
ils ont mangé un pion fonction
progressiste être vérifié de d'alger 3
48 ans me demande si on commentera les
carrés où on commentera les quarts on
commentera les deux mignons qu on entre
à la fille là on commencera tout d'abord
toujours tout le temps j'avais le goût
des noms mais sachant qu'on veut de
guignol là est tout le temps en fait
mais même moi des fois j'ai la merde
c'est lui qui commente un bon jour bien
faut toujours demain soir et un mois
c'est pas pour ça j'aurais regardé le
match pareil mais je dis ça aurait été
bien commenté au moins il est de bon ton
dommage de laisser fifa est ce que tu as
dame vient d'engranger quatre on veut
pas voir pour les blancs les soeurs
attaque et de développeurs et d'akira sa
principale y avait la dame qui
protégeait un par beau temps pour moi
mais bon les lecteurs fixe ou qu'ils
aient le sens mais pour google chrome
est ok
il va revenir avec saddam en d1 fab
ouais ok e et dernière tu as dame
français de dame prend gecas tu chopes
le pion g après tapions passé j'ai aidé
dans la suite de cet essai pas moins de
dix-sept tu m'as ce cas et le cavalier
de shazam sens je suis lasse tout et
c'est reparti mais c'est ça les
candidats solides ventes à la question
quel ton passé tel avantage à se dire
les faiblesses les targets loue partout
les avis allure l'autre avons fabriqué
attaques et menaces dames serena
williams et la pensée de 60 forme
défense est partout il y en a deux
parcours un bon tu défends juste en
cavale et non mais attends je vais faire
quelque chose de beau en fait un bien
fou détroit puis on prend un sens ouais
et dans le style j'ai trouvé cinq à la
gauche 6,9 belle parade s'est longtemps
mais il sait que je veux tu sais que tu
commences à y croire aux trucs sans
défaite
quoi non on ne met donc à l'inversé
sorte volant d'avancé parce qu on a pas
le il peut jouer quatre tours parce
qu'il permet un gros chat qui les écrit
c'est là des résines ah ouais je veux
qu'ils aient fois que je t'ai peut-il
les tortures h aux adeptes
là on nous demande s'il a fait trois
nuls une victoire une narine une ans et
3 nuls ce qu'on appelle au foot clean
sheet la feuille de match propre
j'arrive à ramener le calme vers ces
quatre insurgés en france j'imagine tmb
cinq matches coin sur b siftech araignée
carrier ces quatre jours dame des
dessins mais là ça va être horrible là
il va se faire fixer sur la case de 4
avec les noirs ouais mais ont rejoint
d'attac défunt mari mon tête cavalli g5
quand même tu manhattan des trois échecs
quand même qui est peut-être calcul dame
prend des trois comme ça tu menaces
réclament le fou et 3 hockey dans un des
trois c cabinet
nice / dam des trois dames b3 je voulais
faire rage suite - personnes dépend du
four juste touré feu un ph 6 pourra bien
on va voir un peu fou la zone en grèce
qui va faire
ta malik white qui nous écrit dans le
tchad un truc très vrai le pire c'est
qu'il ait pas à fond magnus
il est très tranquille en plus mais tu
as vraiment l'impression de voir nadal
1er tour de roland garros contre un mais
classé 90e mondial est ok il va le
battre 6 2 6 3 6 1 mais s'est voulu
faire 6 0 6 0 6 0 il aurait probablement
pu passer exactement la vente on parlait
au nom masqué de 7 et sur roger vite
qu'ils avaient des âges 6
il est encore un match mais pour le
trading du consensus avant j'en attends
attention et je vais le montrer ça peut
être c'est très pédagogique la femme l'a
lâchée en train de faire la pédagogie de
haut niveau donc attention là tu dis
ouais cashes trois fuites et je te fais
je te fais le mas de grille tout fera
cavalier projet 8 latour protège la can
have cet effet mais c'est d'abord
compenser ces noms de tous il aurait dû
commencer par français
mais bon je voulais montrer ce truc
pédagogique femme mon logis le vraiment
pas le vrai match de la pédagogie de
très haut niveau donc tourbe et 8,9
cavaillé fc3 ici il faut prendre ces
systèmes d'intermédiaires moi ce moment
alors que les procès 6 4 6 3 h 8 dames
g8 la la tour obligé de reprendre et de
la limmat à l'étouffée un beau match
classique car je pense que tout le monde
le connaît dans le tchat
j'espère vous pouvez cadres et des
joueurs de goût pourquoi voter c'est le
beau jeu du monde dames c4 à ce besoin
de forcer qui devrait trouver vraiment
mieux ils vont renforcer jeudi - grangé
casse je suis victorien d'où des toiles
rose
il est très malin de foucque mon superbe
oiseau imprécise l'est de rennes vous
allez dire toi g8 mais j'aurais fait
bien jouer et je prends une colonne
ouverte
j'ai peur fablite ce soit une nouvelle
victoire pour ça j'ai peur du canard
tête tous rêvent de maintenant faire
tour d2 et touré main bref c'est très
très bien
y'a pas dire lui c'est pas de deux très
beaux pas très beau parce que sur dimpre
en d1 il ya trop de 1.8 de rentrer dans
la finale mais gala tour qui va se
battant c7 et ça va être la pls tout
avec le carré lisse et cissé à l'écouter
parler de bonne humeur
[Musique]
infosys est sur scène je pense sont des
fils ou le veuf ailleurs peut-être fou
17 ya toujours une aventure en déviant
petit à petit quand même fin du passeur
soient le plus simple
voiçi principal
la tour 7 mai vont bouger 5 suffi 1
le zinc j'aime bien quand même que les
truites et de l'eau suffisant mais bon a
été informée c'était vraiment fini la
exemple une minute
un peu comme à chaque fois qu'ils
jouaient ce à quoi cela sert chaque
année quoi tu joues un peu trop et il
n'a pas appelé tenté de s'échapper
devant le char est reste à l'affût pour
reste félin presse les églises ne l'a
serré que peuvent y fait que c'est un
massacre total fou j'ai cinq ans ses
premiers coups que tu étais venu à
l'esprit
l'anc est assez bien et bien c'est
maintenant le fuji seul en scène dans la
foulée d'un navire dans l'eau sous le
roi fut rendue en haïti
c'est un prix direct à apprendre à
apprendre sur la torah your wife c'est
ça qui protégeait et où on pouvait faire
tout ça marrant quand même impitoyable
et pitoyable usher l'agencé magnus des
petites finales impitoyable de la magnus
pour le connaître la danse ou non là
c'est fini
ouais mais bon le bas ou manu s'en fiche
mais royal enfin les fours b1 il garde
la tour sur la colonne et a poussé son
tour comme claude giroux et l'histoire
de la nasa retour à saint il pousse
quand même dans le renault 3 et 6 et
j'avais vu sacré progrès 6 il apprend
que j'ai c'est de l'autre côté tu es là
dont je suis là en face tic j'existe qui
défend bien tout est défendu
mais en fait vous sénat va essayer de se
laisser tomber en fait face aux
gaillards encore se laisser tomber
normalité c'est un peu tombé bon +9 sais
quoi encore je crois que c'était 14 ou
15 g plus fine nous ont écrit le tas
leur nez c'est quelque chose comme ça
mais là cela normalement à moins d'une
baisse de régime de magnus mais sinon on
va on va atteindre le plus souvent là là
on enveloppe le web mobile h au grand
pavois parts du match des vaincus 2 x
louis de la socialisation de sang
possible d'être comme ça c'est d'abord
il est dès lors tous d'échanger ses
pions et devait acquiescer cas par là
bakou
pourquoi est-ce que ruiz est ce que tu
aimes dans l'esprit de la rue mais sans
faire une ruine au score c'était plus 17
voile à 21,4 encore des parties après
ses 34 8 où il y aura les bullet mellal
et plus si sage dans les parties pour
pas parce qu'en ville at his friends
généralement puce est plus 8
donc là on serait déjà plus 17 mais il
reste encore un peu de trois plus de
cheveux
il peut se prendre +20 la marée je pense
qu'il faudra arrêter la saison prochaine
avec les qualifiés en fait un fin ça
sert à rien malheureusement d'un beau
temps pour les pantalons je suis pour
mais quand il autorise un jeu c'est pas
n'importe lesquels nous l'a signifié que
vous chez papa tu étais un point de
qualif avant pour des mac intègre le
tableau un ou deux ça donne un intérêt
tu vois pas tout le temps toujours les
amicaux ouais mais parce que aux échecs
classique en me disait quand il ya s'il
ya plus de gens à se vider
c'est pas que plus de gens me situe en
partie tu es plus ferme ul'dah plus de
temps de réflexion que mieux masquer
était faible et cela pendant les
brivistes us que rien et en plus
en plus t'as pas le temps s'appelle tu
en as tu joues je veux être en partie
dans la soirée sur contrepartie c'est
pas qu'une
ça prouve ma théorie quand on dit ouais
mais en blitz les plus fort gagne pas
toujours
enfin je sais pas mais la dent nous ce
qu'on a vu puisque les partis classiques
dure quatre heures donc là on fait
quatre heures de 8 ses équivalents bahia
moins de surprise sur quatre heures de
mise que sur une partie classique je
suis désolé mais genre beaucoup moins en
fait une partie de match mais j'ai comme
ça c'est la même durée sur la même durée
si tu fais des blitz aussi du fait du
classique
il ya beaucoup moins de chance de faire
les gens prient sur du blitz en fait
avec le même temps imparti en fait les
classiques c'est comme un match de
tennis à jouer sur un jeu pas forcément
il y aurait beaucoup plus de surprises
je n'ai qu'une balle très très molle
donc j'avais très très longs échanges en
version ans est non je sais pas mais
c'est quoi la différence et un sexe à
10h30 trois sets ça dure ça dure 90 line
partie d'ailleurs soit dix minutes soit
six heures si on est vraiment dans le
rapport entre un jeu et trois sets
gagnants fait alors est ok c'est juste
deux surfaces différentes
tu fais plein de plein de matches on
dira très rapide indoor gazon une leur
route et où les matrones pas vraiment en
fait parce qu'entre gaz en indoor et
terre battue et une plus grosse
différence qu'entre blitz est classique
en fait non en fait c'est plus au niveau
du format celanese et dur enfin là mais
tu fais un parallèle quand même jetés
oblige est obligé de faire un parallèle
ouais mais bon tu sais si tu te fais ma
part elle qui a perdu tu es éliminé leur
a prêté l'étais pas je sais pas
vainqueur de jouer un match de france au
foot et aurait des surprises ou où tu te
fais dix matches neuf minutes exactes
non c'est une bonne bonne comparaison
bon en tout cas cette position qu'est ce
que c'est que ça vient de bus où la dame
un peu fragile et qu'elle est blanche de
fos qui font cela très bizarre alors
attention delany furet qu'il ya un jour
à 1100 soirée l'eau ne se prendrait
peut-être pas une si grosse branlée
contre 1 2010 contre 1,2 me grey
si je pense sera à peu près pareil ils
ont fait gagner le match non plus
justin suffit par la maintenance et
quand même l'intéressé c'est ça le seul
intérêt du mal classé
nous voilà à la tiens prends des [ __ ]
alors dû dame prend des cats est ce que
je pensais de la merde on aura envie
hein serait dans l'esprit mais là ça va
pas marcher
mais ces trois vidéos la pile poil c'est
un peu vrai comme son classement blitz
en fait ça il est plus ou moins 3000
envie de ceci tu as des 2980 ou quelque
chose comme ça le président voit pas
comment ils ont arrêté vouliez l'un à
l'autre il peut pas bouger ni l'un ni
l'autre parent j'espère tant d'efforts
tombés c'est comme ça et ça fera plus 10
est déconnecté la gousseïnov nom s'est
reconnecté point de pénalité qui avait
coûté très cher à l'événement contre
nouvelle prendre la tête de ce temps
changent et enfin pas tous c'est comme
une bonne idée si le forez pas mal il
n'y a pas eu de bonnes choses mais non
mais moi je le ferai en mini set le
match en fait je ferai comme aux
fléchettes
j'aime bien les formats mini 7 genre je
garderai le même truc et je fais genre
un set en cinq plus en
5 + 2 1 2e set en trois +2 et un dernier
set en 1 + 1 2 0
bah oui c'est ça que j'allais dire j'ai
envie de te dire c'est comme au tennis
si tu voulais absolument que les matchs
et une durée tu vois déterminé par
ailleurs de thadée manifeste qui dure
une heure théval 6 sur 6 r ça dépend
mais en fait le match et non plus
d'aller d'intention en fait non le
cinquième match ne joue pas contre 2 qui
abriteront en deux sets gagnants genou
ça pour les gens qui ont acheté leurs
places qui ont un truc mais c'est ça et
donc en fait c'est pour ça j'aurais
plutôt mis 17 et j'aurais peut-être fait
en 5 to 5 jeux gagnants quoi cinq
parties ouais avec un tie break avec un
tie break
genre tu fais deux parties de plus et si
ça reste comme ça ben tu joues tout sur
une partie armagh et donc le jeu tant
que ça voulait faire qu'elle prendra 35
le life en échec sur la reprise on
dénote le roi de les bouger de
provenance d'une fourchette premier 06
2011 à 11 et demi un ennemi plus disent
hey donc l'avant il à ces cas où là
c'est qu'on est sûr cérébrale
c'est quand même assez impressionnant
comme match pauvre oublier bien alors le
prochain match va bien ce sera le
toussaint d'ailleurs normalement jeudi
alors je peux essayer de si vous voulez
là pendant sûr et c'est un peu commenté
je vais essayer de savoir qui
quel sera le match illégaux qui joue
allez je vais essayer de vous avoir
cette info chronofoot peut chercher
aussi maintenant non mais c'est bonjour
je cherche
j'ai vu que tu as trouvé vous bon ok
donc avec les blancs un peu meilleure
structure plus compacte l'énorme
concurrence est donc voilà c'est ce
petit avantage pour karl c'est
maintenant une blinde ils sont ces
petites pyramides ou un souvent avec les
pions ces trois 3 des 4 dans le système
de londres il abat saleh dans l'immédiat
l'action de l'ue du coup j'essaie tout
ça bon voilà simplement maintenant il va
sûrement qu'il pouvait savoir sur la
colonne a dû imaginer genre tour à tour
trois quarts comptoir notamment tuent
tous nous les petits tati n'a pas juste
pour trouver un cadre autant qu'elle est
au crédit atteint mon père aussi on peut
jouer à des français 5 des prétentions
sur un cas les trentenaires fouet 5
peut-être on se dirige à l'échangé
secouons selon les verts des 4 pourquoi
pas attends je vais chercher
l'information un autre endroit
apparemment les personnes du staff qui
j'aurais pu parler occupés ne sont pas
là mais
normalement alors il ya un changement de
date apparemment pour le prochain match
ça change tout ouais et le prochain
match
pab c'est vendredi aux dépens le
prochain match c'est le 23 dans ce jeu
et c'est très décalé c'est maxime maxime
contre gries tuque et là du coup si tu
es en grèce
déjà avec l'équipe de france peut-être
que je rappellerai que là dessus même si
je prends note injustement va semer
n'importe moment tu tu dors là on va
voir je sais pas s'ils veulent à des
shows mais mgm gris tchouk blague ça
pourrait être pas mal
j ça pour avoir de la gueule à voir si
les choses parce que valve est
insupportable et nous situe à ça va
faire un espèce de voir ce que ça va
mais je comprends pas en fait la date je
sais pas trop je crois parce que
normalement c'est s était pas prévu
comme ça en fait de base tout en
libérant en donnant notre main change
donc jamais bon planning ne pourra
jamais les choses en fonction pour rodez
d'avions qu'une vache en décembre et le
lundi 23 mai je vais quand même vérifier
à les gens voient un message qui
attendra une confirmation
s'ils ont pu faire une erreur france
vérifier la physique article
la vierge qui est des abonnements
direction ces cinq pour refaire ce
qu'est le plus grand chose dans la 5 et
les cycles le match 23
en fait on encore une heure je langues o
weh à peu près il reste à peu près une
heure de jeu ouais donc ça va être un
c'est le match du 23 août je vais
essayer de vous confirmer sahin comme
comme je vous dis c'est ce qui est écrit
mais je voudrais avoir une confirme mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est une date
que vous pouvez noter sur votre
calendrier parce que ce sera le le big
match est pour toi qui est favori du
match morts
je veux lui redire c'est plus ou moins
50 50
après je donne d'elle parce que il a
gagné un des rares papes du monde cette
fois psychologiquement ça joue toujours
que je sais pas d'être un peu plus les
générations pana il ya mon âge et en
haut de gamme v est là mais je pense et
tout c'est plus un joueur mis en examen
quelques souris tu veux comprendre
sachez le truc de la souris je sais pas
parce que dans un moment tu sais que
celui qui détenait le record du plus
gros lots sur ay si si sûr il sait c'est
qu'il ya une autre plateforme de jeux
sur lesquels les pins ont joué beaucoup
c'était quand même grille tout qu'un qui
est carrément le record de la plateforme
et ses grilles choo qui avait éliminé
dans le dernier tournoi
2 sur l'internet chez ce club karlsson
avaient été éliminés tous qu'ils avaient
éliminés pour moi c'est 50-50 là que je
pense que deux tu me vends un favori je
voulais également encore maintenant les
grilles chaud que c'était quoi m'acheter
contrat porteur du ballon d'or mais
l'idée c'était de bulle explose une
odeur s'arrêtera va être très très chaud
un beau match possible la candeur va
découvrir le parti rapides sont des
toulonnais dans l'est mais devant il y
avait un seul il ya de l'inflation
interne elle la gamme elle même c'est
pas sur internet tellement rapides et
hyper dans les vastes et avoir un plan
marrant leur foule cinq est remonté le
royaume
et bien cette fois ci fixe safer 12 à 1
il peut faire à tout moment derrière
pions prend qui on prend un tour à chis
il aurait pu faire au coude avant
peut-être y possédant découvert la c5
barre des 6 il a plein de choix et en vo
est normal s'il fallait tendre de
réduire la langue de pions très chic et
dwan bonne état de dépenses a atteint
des plus beaux matchs et choqué grille
tout cas une vel wichita nouvelle ça va
valoir son pesant de cacahuètes quand
même et ça ce sera avant les avant les
rappels âge le mot qui me qui m'échappe
avant le grand prix avant le grand prix
finalement juste bon belge aura le plus
important de l'année pour maxime
maintenant pas assez
c'est peut-être la coupe du monde le
match le plus important mais quand le
match était perdu matin de nouveau la
même importance qui revient en fait tu
paies de vacances ils m'ont pris de
vacances ou bien par exemple laisser il
disait que c'était un bon entraînement
c'est speech à savoir un tournoi voilà
le temps un peu éloigné maigrichon j'ai
trouvé que c'était une bonne une bonne
sur un terrain d'entraînement pour se
chauffer j'en discutais avec la drogue
que nous joue sérieusement tour à tour à
4 tours des cas tout pouvoir garder
encore personne travaille à la dette
retour et 8 maintenant mais moi il va
être fait roi f5 convergent et de
l'autre un miroir c'est pas mal ce qui
va chasser la tour en fait
bon tout le monde matt est commencée par
tour g8 ou ré fui
des toits en zinc peut-être tour à 4 est
ce que j'allais dire en le maintenant
que le roi est parti
11.5 ce dont nous avons besoin c'est que
rennes qui arrive et qu'il arrête le
match tu ne peux plus tu tu n'es plus
assez lucides ils comptent jusqu'à ce
jusqu'à 10 c et gus et 9 ne réussit pas
répondre quel jour et on a le meilleur
on en 2012
chantal mans cup pour 16h six noms et la
justice une fois tous les 6 ou très
rares ou peut être pas construit en
partie avec non pourquoi great uk
nouvelle se rencontrent en quarts de
finale my prennent les lots leno blitz
en fait quand ils ont lancé le le truc
qui était de série était fait avec les
lots beats et s'est tenue depuis jour
qui répond qu'à une chute
caruana soso mais pour l'une est donc un
délit car yakine bon bah du coup les que
des affiches en vain car yakine
car yakine champion du monde de 800 fait
donc difficile de faire mieux car le sel
vice champion du monde de bliss qui
touchent pas où il était ferme on s'est
tous les meilleurs du monde en fait là
en quarts de finale et resterait
meilleur donc fatah que des affiches sur
la fiche car le senso c'est fantastique
aussi me bats contre 1,2 à 3.793 double
et chaque attaque et ça peut être
conduit qui avait laissé deux mois je
suis né qui dit qu'ils gagnent qu'un
protocole commotion pour gagner 1 il est
comment ils regardent beaucoup de rugby
[Musique]
les belges fabre mais en compte en cause
ce qu'a dit qin
quand il a dit ouais si vous voulez pas
avoir de problèmes physiques aller jouer
aux échecs
alors là je dis non quel est le vrai
gousseïnov quand tu le vois sur la
caméra fou ça donne pas envie du aux
échecs et de cesser de plus en plus on
chez lui c'est fantastique ça
s'assombrit à la nuit qui tourne chez
pas était d'aider des lumières c est son
visage déjà une plus longtemps plus il
coûtait nuit non engageant son visage
s'est assombri la nation crie fort lui
les quatre têtes de série c'est que
carlos enrique uk mevel et ma caméra
pour moi pas photo entre fait ce qu'ils
ont juste pris les lots tout bêtement en
fait ils ont pris les lobbies ce moment
où ils ont fait le le
le tableau et c'est juste tombé comme ça
en fait ce que maxime avançe sur paris
n'était pas si bien classé que ça en
bits
en fait les classements plus beaux
hôtels de cette année j'ai regardé ce
plat de tennis a fait d'armada du
tableau le côté personnes parce qu'elles
ne restent est juste fait part faire et
donc les internautes préfèrent l'eau on
verra peut être réparé en tout cas il
paraît donc il faut aussi faire rapport
à l'eau la mérule regard direct et si tu
prends par rapport à l'année dernière
nakamura il avait quand même bien bien
exploser maxime non mais il avait il à
l'année d'avant il s'était déjà fait a
explosé au ci contre
contre dung quât mur en fait dans le
death match exhibition
ouais c'est la même chose que sam
exhibition mais j'aimais bien en fait
parce que c'était de joueur invité
c'est pas forcément toujours des tables
joueurs d'ailleurs mais il ya eu des
matches il y avait des matchs sympas et
c'est des mecs du même niveau du cou à
chaque fois je pense je pense qu
objectivement naka est plus fort que
maxime dans ce format perso enfin il a
battu deux fois avec seulement d'écart
quand même enfin c'était pas match serré
prend du galon qu'on ramène à casares
naka tentons sur internet
non mais l'accord n'est pas destiné il
ya rarement des gros tournois des gros
tournois mais il autant là il fait
rarement n'importe quoi et on voit quand
il a joué les hôtels il est bien un haka
faut pas sous-estimer il faut respecter
genre là et d'autres manifs et 2e
entrevoir de l'elysée qu'aucun homme un
des points 2-2 malgré ce qu'ils gagnent
gibraltar ce fait trois ans de suite
qu'ils veulent m je vois par taxer les
gagner jean-maxime mg mais délicate n'a
jamais gagné j'ai plein de fois tu au
colloque la joconde fallait jamais gagné
dans ce temps là et lui trouva suit donc
un appel de 16 des choix ils ont rangé
un peu et puis parce qu'il a oublié tout
ça mais dénonce un bon joueur bon je
pense même que des armes et gagné enfin
c'est horrible heureusement avec des si
ce n'était pas normal qu'on perd 28 à
bien le match est tendu et bien il joue
là ils jouent les clous âge
il va falloir abandonner peut-être
bientôt mais c'est quand même plaisir
pour lui tant je vais regarder un peu sa
tête ce qui s'éclaire n'ont pas envoyé
tout d'abord vers la phobie l'attaqué
d'être aussitôt ma meilleure est
tellement au fond du trou enfin le
pauvre mais en plus je sens qu'il va lui
je n'avais qu'à rallier ces trois jeunes
la tour en 17 matches 1 et tout ça va
train qui le tonton alors temps qu'est
ce que c'est que ça serait surtout
comprendre et 5e au monde 1 8 mai mais
plus rien c'est fini elle va faire
pousser 5e c'est fini ça il vient juste
de lever à pousser 5 des gages aux noms
et c'est horrible il a juste donné une
pièce en fait comme une bombe en réseau
mme banon
mais ok mais c'est facile peut en voir
partir des 8es change des dames du
fassis tu poses qui aura là-bas et sur
le droit l'échangé d'un classicisme
effet raciste ça va gagner énorme
d'ailleurs ça y est je vais sur une
halte est pas mal non mais ça devait
gagner c'est leur jolie médaille était
quand même plus loin mais voilà déjà
énormément et afu des 8es c'est un droit
pour apprend à 6 3 b 5 mois que tu
comptes aux juges avaient oui c'est fini
tu dégages allégeant dans le chat de
check point comme l'assurent le truc des
partis sont dégoûtés un à temps c'était
à l'été dernier qu'elle l'étude a fait
un blessé un pro b se désole t sûr que
ça va b5 je fais c'est fini ça va parce
que je dois faire aussi savent si ce
genre wab et 5 le 6 puis on prend et f6
je redis il gagne quand même a quand
même ne sait pas le respect de l'enfant
c'est pas mal à des cocktails pas de
records ne disent pas mais si ça peut
quand même fait un record alors c'est le
bouton plus énervé mais bon jeu avant
les bulles eu un truc c'est qu'il reste
encore huit minutes il restait deux
parties encore il reste être celle là
une autre encore à la 360 mais c'est
très loin de ce premier lot mais quand
tu perds contre un gars qui est aussi
hulk idée que 2700 automatiquement tu
perds beaucoup de poupe
tu vas y si magnus perd contre moi je
faire 100 points navas hyper contrôlée
non classé alors j'ai pu classement nike
du sénat c'est pas du tout allumer un
bas je sais pas il aurait pu lever les
bras vous faire un truc tu vois les
émissions salle avec des nageuses
étaient tellement de monde
la météo qui fait souvent ça je m'arrête
je suis ton
j'ai pas l'avoir présenté avec dès lors
le sursaut bon non mais c'est bizarre
mais j'ai l'impression je remarque un
truc en grâce ces matchs de blitz mais
depuis longtemps c'est que souvent le
mec le plus fort il est moins bien dans
l'ouverture où ces jolies sa b4 je fais
retour sains et je veux juste montrer
que sur calais des cinq en fait l'idée
c'était fou prendre des 500 prend des
5es dame prend et jouer sur le clouage
mais bkc hyper beau puisque maintenant
si la dame pas et qui a aidé 5 et son
tour mais en fait manu ça l'énervé et
maintenant qu'elle est des cinq ans
alors ou peut-être je suis serein pas
quoi mais hyper fun la dame des dieux le
talonne
mais il parle de moi
[Musique]
mais c'est pour le punir quoi un rayon
de soleil ça j'aime pas g data
[Musique]
non je m'en sortirai ne serait pas le
bout c'est une avancée qui passe en mode
super saiyan qui remonte au montana de
l'année t'imagines l'article de chess
points comme la pls total magnus carlsen
éliminé par le bus n 9 en feu
super saiyan que c'est enough ce serait
marrant qui gagne mais c'est qu'ils
soient à même le même visage
complètement noirci papeete
mais quand on veut plus quand même ne
serait pas mal d'interviews après match
il vient sur notre chaîne de quel droit
vous avez parlé ou parler de record
droit il parle c'est français moi
j'allais personne c'est foutu ma gueule
comme ça
j'adore contraire dans ce truc là il
leur dit mais machin il faut les
défoncer mais dans les bons trucs pas
les coups de poing on n'a plus le droit
quoi genre avant l'état n'a plus le
droit tu le paies pas mais avant tu vois
je râle et les invités font ça à foot
pourquoi j'envoie rugby trop chaud on
sait pas que des choses
mais voilà qu'à les prendre et ça en
fait des bons gars et ses peintures
naturelles normal si en haut de la côte
de la victoire de gus et neuf
associations ce qui sera mille contrats
sur les bookmakers là je suis allée
louis milles ce bloc tôt possible ouais
ils mettent rarement plus mais l'idée à
la dernière grosse grosse cote dans les
trucs un peu connu dans le sport qui
arrivait c'était celle un stairway
lessard champion d'angleterre
du coup est ce que guy boucher nowshera
le leinster les échecs on va vous dire
j'ai quoi pas le nom mais là je pense
que sa cote en réalité c'est franchement
ces 10000 en fait mis le feu à une
remarque dans ces matches faciles magnus
perd sa connexion internet ce qui va se
reconnecter du thar jath aux restes de
corps des bonhommes dans les paris
rendue à sion bon bah
ça dépend c'est comme les y organisa des
sous le nom mais sur ozil ça dépend des
bookmakers y en a qui plane quand même
si le premier set a été fier même des
bookmakers si le premier point a été
joué à un jeu propre enquête et je les
suis là je sais pas du coup difficile
donner une cote exacte des 10000 ukulélé
qui bordeaux invaincus en ligue 1 au
début du championnat
c'était 5000 contre un magnat bordeaux
qui finissait invaincu de ligue 1 dès
5000 barils
mais c'est impossible et des parias de
la côte de barr sa part est en fait le
barça fois qu'ils étaient à 8 contre 1
ou 10 contre 1 pour se qualifier
la remonte à das était pas le truc
incroyable ouais ses niveaux d'avant le
truc c'est que si une équipe peut le
faire c'est le barça mais même là mais
je vais pas me lever 25 comprenais pas
mais gagner c'est le barça masculine
elle est masquée nous as a calmé le
masque wink loupe pas une meilleure
façon à brouiller leur dit non non non
mais je tenais je te mêler les vraies
côtes si tu prends les côtes de
bookmaker genre tu prends plus pinnacle
et tu prends de bookmakers en fait les
côtes d'un copain c'est du 100% en fait
ça yaya personne qui gagne ou si tu me
sur les deux tu perd pas d'argent je
faisais mes vraies côtes et cotes des
bookmakers anglais et si tu prends de
bookmaker différents
où donc sûrement pas trop ce qui fait
qu'au sénat hôpital et tombeur wes que
faire surtout prophétie se faire tour
ces avancées c'est bon les gars ont
battu pas sûr qu'ils soient encore
gagnant du tout en fait un bond de
dégâts mais les quartiers penser les
manquions on retrouve le trône mais il
peut même la perdre en fait bizarre
alors aux réflexions qu'on me dise
et on cerne du coup sûr des cas tu vas
faire quoi il va faire voir mon problème
c'est ce que j'allais dire manger des
rois roi ici de quoi s'est tenue à ceux
des trois des deux mains non enfin tu as
des trois rois ces trois tours c1 et
après tu plus l'un ou l'autre et après
de faire vous êtes cet orgueil deux
d'affilée la boue la date où le satio
jour tega dire qu'à dire aux gars à dire
a tendance à faire dame en même temps
cette histoire c'est chaud non mais en
fait je suis pas sûr là j'ai un peu peur
pour gagner en fait celle ci on chante
il va la gagner un gars dit tu as à dire
olé
et voler comme les garder mais sur la
n17 tour c'est cette même perdu toutes
ses chambres à il voit déjà que nos c4
détroit n'ont pas la même chose que les
problèmes de connexion en plus au-delà
de 5 à dire non mais là les leurs en pls
mais total sur la caméra des séquelles
et bézy c'était une blague marrant dr
bouchard agadir
oui mais j'aime entraîner des trois
derniers cas quoi effectivement
chevalier en ce moment à les acheter
nous on aurait le match 5 thèmes pour
nous connaissons n'a pas réfléchi
longtemps comme ebay ou leur fassent
longtemps et la mienne il dit le gym
bien tassée et ans dans le vrai français
le geste prononce de la france et les
français demeurent tu as toi déjà ton
toit très rarement l'infinitif j'ai
remarqué
gagner liberté mallory gagné une partie
c'est pour parler français
nous avons
bien bien c'est qu'il va pas gagner
beaucoup d'argent ce truc là où c'est
une oeuvre qu'en fait ils ont les prix
sont partagé est un mec qui prend des
prix pour la qualif et après tu as une
autre partie des prix qui est partagée
au pourcentage le parti qui a gagné dans
le match et la tenir et et de la dire en
france il va pas apprendre grand chose
on peut réguler tout y était pas
comprendre chez nous des fêtes de 11 0%
gilbert nice et au score je crois avec
nuls tu prends un peu quand même un bon
quand même
qui alors peut-être que fiat bref 4 à
première vue n'avait voulu faire [ __ ]
en g3 et reprendre 1,4 en fait s'il faut
laisser 4,6 voulait prendre prendre g3
et s'en prendre à eux quatre bon sens
qui a pas que ça qui bloque le fouet du
coup je ne vous explique pas ce qui se
passe c'est trop simple pour moi tu
perds tu aimes pour conséquence la non
je te fais d'un match 3 ses faits
d'armes h3 tu dégages je te fais qui a
régné h karaté je te matt manson est
d'où l'idée de dames c'est de commencer
à comprendre la partie la petit à petit
c'est finalement c'est intéressant là
comme discussion comprenait pas du tout
ce qui se passait a du coup on comprend
que et b4 aussi et surtout comprendre la
main en train de faire une échappée
incompréhension damas et trois à damas
trois oui mesdames français quatre
peut-être là là là là puis on comprend
ce qui se passe c'est horrible hongrois
champions ouais mais romain non tu vas
tu rez-de-chaussée à satory femmes oui
il avait été obligé mais bon bref
l'ipad qui prend 1,5 à un an et à la
dame qui protège oui mais bon la dame
avait surchargé je sais pas dans mes f
déjà être étranger il assure lui verser
4 voici la loi
les gens pensent que tu t'en piffre de
dooku le coup ouais mon linceul est
clairement j'ai des cornes de gazelle
n'était pas trop corne de gazelle film
c'est très bon mais en fait je suis plus
salé que sucré et du coup ça allez tu
crois quand quoi vont tous deux très
bons les tajines engins jim bien ici on
vous agadir et est plein de poissons
dont j'aime les poissons sont bons j'ai
créé mon saint pierre vincent mengin je
rencontre sont vaines voiture un
marocain dispose pas d'un auteur
français c'est très bien aussi un peu
mais je veux dire j'étais tellement
d'endroits où on fait la nourriture est
pas bonne que là en fait ils ont gagné
une vraie ils ont une vraie envie de
cuisiner un truc bon vin le cohérent
qu'on va pas juste je suis en importe
donc intéressant non ils sont cohérents
par mais je sais pas mais tu es joueur
tu veux tu vas en angleterre tu vas des
états unis s'est pas ouvrir la bouche
bée il est en quelque sorte un peu le
philippe etchebest des échecs quel
philippe etchebest
je vais de gasoil chef fait une émission
sur m6 ben ouais
le guide du routard des secousses et
l'italie quand même qui reste un peu au
dessus en baisse de très différent mais
j'aime beaucoup l'italie est bon il va
faire très attention à ce que tu vas
dire plus creuses
non je leur livre
aouidat l'étranger dans la soirée
caliente façon très bien oui dans
l'étude les pays que je mettrais mais
bien au niveau nourriture day à la
française camille ya le maroc et j'aime
bien certains trucs asiatiques dont le
fast-food asiatiques à côté de la gare
ouais recommandé par l'ada en fait
recommandé par tripadvisor aussi mais
par delà d'avant fête mais n'importe
quoi dont il va rester trente minutes de
match enfin le seul suspense est ce que
magnus va réussir à faire plus 20 à plus
à voir c'est possible c'est très
possible que pour ses sorts en fait le
pari intéressant c'est 50 50 + 20 ou
plus doit pas plus loin ouais le
handicap 19 25 19 25
mais c'est chaud ça en même temps la
ukulélé à nice et vannes qui l'a
recommandé à tripadvisor exactement ça
va reprendre de trois minutes
ban en fait tripadvisor en fait se sa
ligne ou complètement sur les avis de
bladen fait ça qu'on va dire qu'un
d'utilisateurs sur ce site c'est pour ça
que tout le monde le va tourner le
plébiscite en fait sa une sur dix en
fait tu assures vlad advisor c'est très
intéressant connais tous les hôtels
connais tous les grands chaque don ce
jeune talent de celui-ci j'aime bien
aussi mais qui est disons dès maintenant
la main je trouve pas la musique à
raffiner
voilà ça ils sont pas connus pour le
raffinement niveau bouffe dire les
candidats à berlin que va-t-on manger
fable quand on y sera je ne sais pas
c'est le point commun c'est bien ça va
être sympa tu vois cette fantastique
tonton kaka il dit ici c'est genève
voilà c'était pas très peur quand même
le ici ces jeunes affluent tu ne te dis
pas le stade de genève
ouais non mais c'est pas ça va être
n'importe quel club en fait ça c'est pas
le déplacement qui fait peur
et vegan à base de wok de légumes
graines de soja rem moi j'aime bien en
fait
non ça va faire comme je suis pas très
légal mais pourquoi pas mais moi je dis
que c'est pas mal en fait vegan mais bon
non mais c'est bien le même stack avec
la franchise au ficg du truc en fait
mais bon du coup juste que les paviens
déplace en fait un peu les mêmes plats
mais on vegan quoi enfin se faire des
petits falafel des trucs comme ça c'est
bon aussi mais il trouve panier
uniquement c'est quand même pas mal
ceci est une poésie je suis plutôt
d'accord sans vous ne gardez pas les
bonnes questions
non mais on dit si tu es d'accord la
vache une enfant lâché une info qua non
mais même moi pas évident à faire
non mais toute la question c'est est-ce
que fais-je et armstrong leur tasse et
végétarien mais ils mangent du poisson
ouais je me verrais plutôt comme ça mais
aussi dans sa journée va pas c'est
qu'avec ma mère une fois les murs tu as
musique et le poisson les animaux bavay
levée immédiate pourquoi tu comprends
l'idée pourquoi les animaux se
trouvaient les poissons seraient
inférieurs enfin je sais pas ça ne sert
à rien de demander quoi bon le mec il
meurt quand même enfin c'est horrible à
voir du saumon le mec il meurt
fédérer c'est comme si on te noies
coiffage et raf numéro noyer qui fait tu
parles c'est horrible le second cas lui
repart ils meurent noyés
c'est hyper cruel comme mort ils vont le
champ dollon bah oui mais c'est
l'équivalent d'être moyens mais surtout
à quoi ils essayent de respirer ne peut
plus nager paca + 3 non c'est dans
l'esprit du débat c'est bon moi je mets
un petit handicap d'un petit pion
mais en tout cas ça fait par les gens
dans le tchat vous avez dit non mais
éthiquement suis assez d'accord
non en fait c'est une question pourquoi
les végétaux sera fermée du grand chef
c'est juste que les végétaux enfin en
tout cas on imagine qu'ils souffrent pas
quand on les a si les 6 et 7 juin aucune
branche non en fait les gens te prends
ce qui commençait à dire que oui souffre
quand tu leur copine moi en ce moment
ils n'ont pas de système nerveux et tout
ça donc il va vraiment souffrir ses plus
hauts niveaux de la souffrance quoi mais
moi je voulais pour manger un truc non
mais moi je suis convaincu je te jure un
truc dont je suis convaincu c'est pas un
jeu je saurai jamais si j'ai raison mais
je suis sûr que tu reviens dans 300 ans
400 ans si encore l'être humain donc ça
la fumette du coup inspiration 20 soit
là messi encore l'être humain je suis
quasiment sûr que l'on mangera plus de
viande c'est comme la violence a
beaucoup baissé tout ça les gens quand
même bon voire des compliments les
compléments alimentaires
non mais c'est pas ce qu'on mange ramé
mais évite saveurs juste un mauvais set
mais bon ce match roddick et branche 3
je suis pas d'avis à pour aller toucher
nous allons perturber un vêtement
ben tu prends être captées tombe bien
c'est beau la meuse 5
khadir s'est un peu trop le beau jeu bah
c'est pas vrai s'est pas bougé trois
dames h 2 mais bon il fait peut-être un
peu trop de bourges où il aime bien les
dire
sur salaire prendre dans mes films et
aux mêmes s'attaquent à un petit
problème surgit petit nul d'affaires à
roanne 3e aux cavaliers c'est un pas
dans son enfant mais ses parents si tu
as les délais de boissons seront solides
damas est fantastique
car si c'était le bon du tout gagner
s'ils gagnent comme ça n'est vraiment
pas mon slip lâche 3 bourgogne a6
bon plus 13 mai pour les plus bas là les
mecs qui ont parié sur le plus souvent
ils sont heureux enfin c'était une
partie c'était chaud la coupe du monde
du 100 % pour le plus après le fait de
pas gagné deux parties enfin il ya eu de
la chance un sac il a gagné quand même à
gagnières félidés gagnant un premier
temps mais après il était malin de
primes technique exemplaire pour
convertir en effet une pièce en diamants
et à tout prendre et 6 passes et 5 venir
vers le stade du lit la juste un pion de
plus simple il va peut-être leur père
mais non mais du coup ça va ramer ouais
c'est pas été confirmée je ne sais pas
mais je vis de ghadir la cheval il m'a
l'air d'être mis en bullet que des cas
ils disent à la normale
non mais il se défend pareil quand même
nom mais sûr de la partie d'avant l'été
des choses il ya trouve lui faire le
beau jeu à un moment c'est parti avec la
dame et tout s est octroyé le puissant
le faire
ces choix ont promis son camp celui des
gamins prennent ça siens pour les blancs
quand même s'amuser
buntin beaucoup peut-être même pas moins
bien en fait je pas exagérer travailler
avec vos proches
oui j'avais mon côté je sais pas sur
quoi il a pas fait tour des deux en fait
j'aurais commencé par tours d2 pour
défendre la sienne je veux pas du sang
aulas mais c'était pas de 40 tours des
bus quand même bien tu protèges tout et
puis après tu pousses 5 nuls comme ça
soit c'est ce qu'il a parié sur les plus
hauts revenus sans ces choses je prends
battre en fait ce qu'il fait parce qu'il
est en train juste de venir
enfin il vient juste d'offrir six coups
gratuits en fait le pudding ma benz et
qu'en fait il a offert tous les cra les
noirs avaient envie de jouer ça toute
façon que de 0,1 au québec cependant la
technique il aime trop aux différences
sont venus s'ajouter l'échangé d'un les
lacunes
y'a pas tout gagner quand même pas mal
qu'ils admirent nom à la bouche riche de
pop âgée page et parmi le temps mince
moi c'est plus ou moins quart d'heure
maintenant il convient de partir bull
est en 2e et 3e
ça a pris il doit rester peut-être quand
même deux minutes ans quand je passe mes
22 au hasard et g5 plastique bleu bah
oui enfin pour moi c'est vrai échec là
qu'ils sont en train de se jouer devant
mes yeux c'est la vraie cadence et les
vrais échecs c'est tout vous fin tout
est là en fait venir du monde lorsque
j'avais pour quelle raison se veut un
moment décisif c'est qu'elle a aimé
faire ce qu'ils ont deux options noirs
et là j'allais te dire tu es
complètement à l'encontre de la théorie
moderne
il a mal à sa déprime
menace rien et tout et puis après c'est
le petit reproche pour faire à manu
c'est quand même malgré l'écart et tout
ça elle a toujours voulu jouer ces
petites finales verront ils massacrent
tellement avec les sports qu'il est
quasiment à 100% pour quoi ils votaient
mardi pour avoir un début de l'écho et
aigus maladie très dangereuse
non mais toi tu es très bon
techniquement d'armes et sa technique sa
carrière j'ai quand même quand il foule
barbe réalise enfin pas vous y pouvait
faire que ça quoi non mais si vous
voulez jouer l'attaqué jouer à fond et
tout mais inutilisée faire appel à un
plan de jeu était marche très très bien
pourquoi s'être adressé à pleyben f7
noms et qualités six volets ci peut tout
faire
je ne sais pas ce que deviennent fous
ont mené dans d'évitement il reprend 1,5
et peut-être six échecs à prêter change
sous tendent et 8 en fait non à la
demande conjointe ça quand même trois
avions depuis sa marche en avant
cette quête
voyez résisté prouve qu'il existe
organisé par le monde je veux jouer le
plus longtemps possible pour 1 kg et le
moins de partir faites pu jouer au beach
en floride il peut il peut gagner la
tournée
une dame neuves alors qu'aux nôtres
question f3 non mais par explosion
combien c'est dur hein est-ce qu'il peut
inventer pour voir the screen
mais attends j'ai un soucis de caméra
ouais c'est un peu embêtant
j'essaie de remettre
gaillard s'est inspirée par la caméra
mais moi je peux tu être ma caméra sous
confinement beauté ça marche à l'essaie
un finish en confort tac me voilà à
temps georges tron l'a pas fait depuis
tout à l'heure ce truc là on support
n'oublions pas au début ça marche et
trovan je n'étais pas sous le même
réseau c'est avec moi la plupart ya un
petit moment
tant pis quoi salut tout huit chevaux
mais alors la parole pour les blancs ça
va encore mais elle s'est passé pour lui
je sais pas encore comment ça semble
inéluctable ah ouais ça se passe comme
ça de toutes les parties en fait même là
tu peux prendre j'ai tout prendre un
tour non il faut bien n'est ce pas soit
il suffit juste à mes fils que ready en
fait ça passe juste gagner une caisse
ouais
simple illusion bataclan il va te faire
enc de les automates et moi je suis
jeune j'ai vite quoi d'autre mais bon on
a tous des 400 m dames des landes
combien organes tous les français mais
sur des toitures en berne
ouais je demande ce truc attendu tour 8
intermédiaire bataille à sa manière en
berne le buzz
mais fougères un échec non voilées et
tour à 3 g iii et ça c'est joli ce qui
peut amener je sais pas de route et fait
un père fait en fait ouais mais leurs
hôtes intérieur une fois je sis dans ce
site
je pense qu'il voudrait faire mieux que
nul en fait même pas mal par une souris
nul jusque 15 et à peut-être et il
résiste aux manifs 3162 mais elle aura
sauvé quelques petits demi point par ci
par là
à un moment il a qu'une victoire une
victoire quatre nuls
maïs et du leur a balancé h4d qui vont
être aux anges et 645 très rapidement le
maire de l'harmonie rappelé sur ma guise
donc je sais pièce où le truc
avec manu ces pièces sont toujours bien
placés
mcconnell sont pas déplacés il va
falloir trouver un moyen de bien la
romaine est parfois encore et une petite
grimace magnus
bon ça change tout c'est 9 de gagner tu
vas y vas y vas plus grand du rouleau je
suis pas sûr je pense toujours à cette
gamescom a le matériel du coup ça
devient bon cela remet un détourage le
nom
on reste avec est pas super bien placé
mais bon
forcément là elle obliger ainsi en d2
soit soigné de pions b2 qui tombaient
mais là c'est un peu la galère septembre
un gain de 5 6 me 9 % voilà tu peux pas
t'en sortir
ok tu mates et non en oui elles sont
encore tissot mais bon la machine check
marne et d'en prendre soin
ok
du caylar dégoûté a perdu la partie by a
plus l'habitude bon tu vas probablement
pas réussir à faire le plus pointu
arrive à rester dans le matelas mais bon
la physionomie du match aura été plus
cruelle encore contre petrossian dans le
sens petrossian un moment donné je
préfère gagner une ou deux parties
d'affilée les faits intrigants
gousseïnov va que tirer des nuées mais
il n'ya plus de caméras plus rien de bon
elle durera bon c'est 6 le donne acheté
7 5 il veut y aller
mais je pense que si gousseïnov genre
tous les jours contre ma muse pendant un
an
est ce que dans un temps pareil il
progresse petit à petit en fait marqué 5
points 4
non mais je reste que ça le ferait genre
vraiment progressé genre tu joues
pendant un an le mec te parle et où est
ce que tu progresses grave ou pas bah tu
joues balises sur youtube analyse c'est
ce qu'on en fait je pense à un truc le
mec là mischa zverev en fait au tennis
voilà je ris joué pas mal j'avais déjà
vidé ma celui sur gazon et où il s'est
quand même toutan défoncé il n'était pas
régulier et tout et tout d'un coup il ya
son frère qui est complètement percée et
maintenant il est 20e mondial par un 27e
j'ai regardé la ce matin et en fait
avant il était genre aux alentours de la
150e place mondiale de vous préparer
pour ça non mais je pense fortement de
seconde des mecs comme ça y est tu paies
revue de fin après sans faire des
matches comme ça tu veux aussi faire des
matches à thème sur une ouverture tu
bosses de chacun de son côté
toute la joie font en voiture analystes
eurent fait et tu pourrais avoir compris
pas mal pas mal mais bon quand même dur
la pollution les seuils de la mer mais
cette bo sont déplacés chiant de voir
celui qui allait devenir sur le capot
c'est cool d'un match 3 pendant 1 s'est
qualifié cinq échecs aller vers le 4 mai
la séparait cycle pions des ondes et
écroué
les petits trucs et diane n'est jamais
un bellini d'attac g6 peur d'être lent
même quand les parents apprennent les
étrangers 80 ans exactement
mais peut-être sur les ressources et
sadek al hijé 5 après qu'ils ont déjà
dépassé
on repasse à +16 on a en plus 15ème
place d'être des têtes au milieu des
trois ans comporte des deux produits
bernard kg 6 h 4 en seulement 1 h 15 une
chose à à 5
dans le même esprit ipad ou pas par où
je t'ai vu faire des tranches de phase
iii avec la tâche qui attend beaucoup
on s adresse en place sa skoda et attend
une menace g5 s'est fortement ce
quelqu'un il va falloir trop de casse
pendant qu'elle a compris que les pions
c'était de la merde quand même après
ouais mais bon des quatre il joue pas
mal gousseïnov j'aime bien le jeu ces
temps de jeu près des lignes de basse et
ça c'est peut-être pas les meilleurs
coups mais au moins il est temps des
positions et cas et b3 les boums
n'espère qualité voilà boom français 5
dégage revient en b3 gauche droite
donc j'ai cinq portes et bientôt un
outil des cinq peuples rythme sa maman
fait ok ça te met un plus pour le roi
rebond du mois souvent très bien très
bien car ie8 fond de court réa castrol
honda
la tête ont fait à trois intermédiaires
aussi bon une fois encore rien ne fais
pas le malin tu avais pas eu non plus
attention qu'avant th 5 tout à fait
l'intention très chaude mais c'est le
portel
j'ai envie d'être dans l'esprit à fond
tu vas faire d'anelka des trucs ça me
bouffe wave 5 damas trois échecs et
touchant sais c'est pas très bon mais
bon peut-être tour des huit échecs et
ouais non moment il est dans les bons
coups comme quoi qu'ils disent est
nettoyé salles américaines dans la tour
parce que tu m'as âmes français pour mon
petit poney pas le retour des tireurs
dame prenait froid là et sur food d'un
proche
je pense qu'il va se tourner il faut
chance ou faire le beau jeu ces
provisions nul de maxine de maxime mode
magnus nulles les chances que vous savez
n'avait pu aller faire le beau jeu x
10.3 quand même fadq en même temps même
merde j'aurais pu non mesdames près
trois fois l'an prochain de 300 contrats
à voile a réclamé la somme des 6 manyu
sauf ceux liés plus non
non mais vingt joueurs quant à un tel
score et tout a peut-être envie d'aller
gagner une partie comme très mûr tu as
gagné une partie où il portait pas
l'argent qui viennent et on y pointent
les dollars enfin il va quand même à dix
on a un gros coup les infos jeunes comme
beaucoup je sais pas c'est le budget
j'ai dû tout nouveau battu voix
c'est de respect chaque fille la kalach
un supporter ou en dessert est ouest et
qui reprend du piment dessin aujourd'hui
si c'est en croisez vous prendre quelle
épreuve lancée si c'est ou peut-être l
intrigue est une arme x existe fort et
en champions prend d'abord en fait le
croire avec lui bon il faut compter 3
ses fonctions et est un combattant il
capture mon appel au mouvement les sites
qui traînent les gars ça a fait en fait
voilà bien passé ces stress de coeur des
monts c4 glisser le rôle cousu sur ton
plus de bart où s'arrêtent et n'arrivent
pas à utiliser food et 5 et puis on
s'écarte super fort en fait le roi des
morts
tous les côtés je suis en 20 03 mois
c'est bien ça nous permet d'activer le
roi de déloger in fou mais ok avec vous
ces neuf resourceful dans le petit jeu
tactique que dans le petit périmètre ils
[Musique]
sont un peu comme ça c'est à dire twingo
et au mini fouine non mais il te trouves
dati qui piègent des trucs qui vous
invite tous à ses fins mais ceux qui
sont admis tactiquement soient insultés
l'a peut-être ces 3 1
hiroshi à la peur mais peut-être que le
fragment des trois mais je vois pas trop
comment mais même
d4 et où la première finale que boucenna
joue bien en fait du match
il réduit un peu de chance que j'aie
synchronise c'était bien et s'il est fou
mais de qui contre-attaqué a tous
ressenti n'est pas fait gaffe a choisi
son projet sis est ici à thoiras tigers
quelque chose d'important hydrolien
car c'est la dernière partie de rien ole
téléphone à la main d'henry il s'en sort
très bien en fait poussé enough
il va se prendre le plus de temps que je
n'ai vu un truc amélie charlesbourg bon
match ils se battraient très bien
finalement en bullet c'est là qu'ils
auraient été le plus résistant ne sauve
pas qu'ils tombent quand même ce que
s'ils tombent à l'abri nulle ce débat
l'eau quand même
violement finit plus beaux masques ali
et ses goûts ses neuf s'il tombe ce
serait ballot
on progresse pas mal thibout sign of
regarde ok c'est beau pour lui qui gagne
finale finalement delphine basse et
samassa lutte est vrai qu à +14 examen
du net on budget sera bien résisté alors
on disait la foudre et la primauté déjà
passé vraiment résolue elle prône une mc
oui ou non c'est sûr mais bon j'arrive
mans il finit sur une note positive
non c'est bien sûr des temps ps dans une
caméra ousmane bah il est plus les plus
de caméras l'un il était tellement
intéresse qu il est très calme
ben pas mal
oui tu vois finalement en fait comme il
a bien résisté en bullet sans but la
carf ouattata d'état des joueurs qui
s'écroule complètement et prennent genre
+8 +10 et l'abus fait qu'ils se soient
pas écroulé en bullet va le score et
passifs à ok c'est il persévérer tous
mes inspirations suis sur une table donc
au final 28 euros
ça va pas mal pas mal finalement
s'arrêter moins un million de ça aurait
pu l'être en fait ce pari fini sur une
bonne note et par voilà c'est ça la boue
rouge
ouais après je sais pas comment ça se
serait passé si match était plus serré
en ce qui concerne le fait qu'il est
temps la caméra puisse commencer une
obligation on mais là il n'a pas été
sévère heureusement une tonne de canne
heures après pause
oui il emmenait dans vos pieds michael
bay témoigner vous laissez moi aussi un
mepha prochains matches denses et le 23
mai heures à 19 heures pour
pour le match de maxime en fait 22 morts
on est sur le nom ouais enfin annoncé
samedi 23 octobre
normalement mais bon soit disant dire
marché semaine prochaine on n'est jamais
sûr de rien non nous attendre à des
coups bas relations officielles et aux
emplois sur 10 très bonne soirée tout le
monde
ciao ciao